all right people we are live on the
World Wide Web
YouTube for as long as they'll let us
remain here I'm gonna be live for two
hours today we got a lot to talk about
it's time to to get real we're gonna
level about a few things I'm gonna share
some insight into sort of what's going
on with the show with patreon with the
future I know you guys have a bajillion
questions and I've got a lot of answers
we'll do ask me anything we're gonna do
a little a little fundraising for the
show but before I do anything I feel
like most importantly I just got to
catch you guys up on sort of where we're
at at the moment and just briefly a
little bit on my adventure to get here
and and sort of where we're at so as
most of you guys know I launched on
patreon we launched the Reuben report on
patreon about two and a half years ago
it was June of 2016 and at the time
right before that we had obviously had
the show on The Young Turks for about
two years then we were very briefly at
riot which was a startup and just we
sort of were going in different
directions everyone there was great but
just didn't work out
and then we were at aura TV and aura
back in September of 2015 is where I had
my first interview with Sam Harris it
was the first time I had done a sort of
one-on-one interview on camera and that
basically when that when the show ended
I was like whoa that's what I want to do
like that's the best thing that I've
done it was real and it was raw and it
was important and relevant and true and
I was like that's what we're gonna do
and really that was the day I think if
I'm not mistaken it was September 9th
2015 is when our first show on aura went
up it was the one with Sam Harris and my
life changed and that's where the show
started blowing up and then subsequently
you know we started going more and more
into the free speech space and and then
all of the things that I now care about
we stayed at aura till till about May of
2016 and at that point I realized at
aura was great by the way and we were at
aura because Larry King who is the
greatest interviewer of all time bar
none he welcomed us there he I mean he
welcomed me to do an interview show on
his Network pretty pretty freakin great
and Larry's become obviously a friend
and mentor to me in any event the show
was really blowing up and what we
realized were was basically was that we
were kind of we were sort of getting
bigger than the network at some level
and I thought you know what we can do
this alone I want to I want to own the
show I want to control what we're doing
I want I want to be my own boss and and
figure out how to grow a business here
and all of these things and then we
launched on patreon in June of 2016 and
the night before we launched on patreon
I said to David and Amir oh who joined
me left their jobs we all quit our jobs
and left our health insurance and all
that stuff just to try this thing and we
had no idea whether it was gonna work I
said to them man I I may have really
screwed up the night before we launched
I was like I don't know what's gonna
happen tomorrow but within hours of
launching we realized that we were gonna
hit our fundraising measures the markers
that we wanted to hit and then we went
independent we rented a studio for for
about six months after that and then
when we fully fully fully achieved
independence was two years ago
almost it was two years ago in November
so a little over two years ago when we
were able to buy this house and now we
absolutely control and own and operate
everything that we're doing I'm super
proud of the small business that we've
created here the same things that I
talked about about personal
responsibility and limited government
and all of these things and and the
classical liberal and libertarian ideas
that I that I talk about all the time
are the same ways that I try to run my
business we pay a hundred percent of our
employees health insurance we've got
we've got part-time we're his full
timers all these things and I'm just I'm
thrilled and elated about everything
that's happened here now I should
mention because I think most of you are
watching this right now because of the
patreon situation that for the two two
plus years that we were on patreon
everything was fine
there was the incident where they booted
Lauren southern off the platform and I
had jack conte a little about a year and
a half ago sit in that chair right over
there and tell me that they were not
going to police speech on their platform
that what Lauren had done was
taken part in what he termed manifest
observable behavior meaning behavior not
just words behavior that she had
partaken and I don't even want to get
into the specifics of everything that
she did or didn't do it doesn't even
matter actually but he said words
themselves he said to me I think he said
it on camera but he certainly said it
off camera I would never run the risk of
being booted now first off he's just one
guy that happens to run the company
right now that's nice to hear I suppose
but also it's like well I don't want to
be on a platform that everyone else
might be getting booted off of but I'm
just getting some assurance that I'm
safe I think you do know that I care
about free speech and free expression
and all that so anyway he said manifest
observable behavior is what will get you
booted if they if you do something off
platform that's an actual action not
just words manifest observable behavior
M OB the acronym mob mob behavior you
can't make that up
but that's what they said we do it
anyway a couple a couple weeks ago I
guess it's about a month and a half ago
now beginning of December patreon booted
sargon of akkad
carl benjamin who also has sat in that
seat over there and who I've done
collaborations with over the years who's
a classical liberal from the UK who
years ago when I was still on The Young
Turks and I was really waking up to what
was going on with the Left related to
free speech and calling everyone a
racist and a bigot and a homophobe and
the rest of it and realizing how
illiberal the Liberals had become
everybody online was saying you've got
to talk to sargon of akkad he's the guy
he's been doing it forever he's putting
up all these videos anyway I did talk to
him and I think that that actually
started some of my success in this space
anyway about a month and a half ago they
booted him off patreon with no warning
because he used the n-word on a video
from February so from about ten months
prior on someone else's channel not his
channel and not a video that was even
posted to patreon now he used the word
because he was using the all rights
language against them this guy is
against the alright he's an old-school
liberal I don't want to even get into
every little specific of every little
thing that he has said but he is someone
that debates all right people okay so
but the real point here is not even this
six of the words it's that it's
something that he said off platform not
even on his own channel so it wasn't
like he was doing something on his
channel that wasn't on patreon and they
said well you're funding that through
patreon it was something that was on
someone else's Channel altogether they
booted him there was no recourse there
was no warning and this was obviously
just a a truly massive move of the line
and Sam Harris canceled his patreon a
couple weeks ago Jordan Peterson and I
have announced that we are canceling our
patreon On January 15th this is the
engine of the show this you know we're a
hundred percent fan funded here you guys
you were 100% independent really its
independence more than anything else
because of you guys so this is a major
risk that I'm taking I'm volunteering
giving up about 60 to 70 percent of our
monthly Rev because I think it's the
right thing to do and and I know that a
lot of you guys are with me so there's a
really interesting thing happening right
now I'm watching our our monthly Rev go
down but I'm feeling very inspired
because I'm getting so many messages
from you guys who are telling me you
know I'm gonna stand up for something
just like you are so it's pretty cool
okay so let me just do a couple little
pimp shoutouts right here up top just to
tell you what we're doing and then we'll
we'll go more back into the story and
everything else so first off we are
closing our patreon January 15th we are
trying to move everybody over to Dave
Rubin dot-com / donate and what what
that's all about is it it doesn't solve
the biggest problems related to
censorship yet it doesn't solve the
biggest problems related to payment
processors and things like that but it
does remove one portion of the middleman
here we don't need patreon anymore it's
not like anyone's discovering us on
patreon they're they're taking a cut of
the money and they're doing practices
that I don't believe in so we're trying
to get as many people as possible that
have supported us on patreon or new
people over Dave Rubin comm / donate and
and help support the show we'll see what
happens like there are many other ways
that I can go about supporting the show
I could be reading ads and I could be
joining networks and all those things I
like being independent I think we've
done something really cool here and and
it's really on on you guys to see what
the what the future will hold so what
we're gonna do though for this
livestream is if you donate 25
bucks monthly while we're doing this
live stream for the next two hours you
are gonna get a Reuben report Reuben
Select t-shirt now these were the
t-shirts there are a limited amount of
these that it will never be printed
again because these were the t-shirts
that we were given away to our patrons
so there's a couple hundred of them left
and if you donate $25 or more monthly
while I'm doing this you're gonna get a
t-shirt I should be selling like crock
pots or something I'm wearing that
t-shirt right now as you can see and if
you donate fifty dollars or more right
now during this live stream we're gonna
send you a Reuben report mug this is a
select member mug that was only for our
patrons we've got a couple hundred of
them left I'm gonna sign it for you
right here and give you a shout out and
anyone that donates say five bucks or
more during the live stream I will give
you a shout out as well so I've got to
trust the iPad here my team's gonna be
sending me names telling me what you
guys are doing I'll answer all your
questions related to all of this I just
think it is time to take a stand it is
just time to take a stand I don't take
any great pleasure in this I don't want
to fight patreon and I don't want to
fight Google I don't want to fight any
of these things I want to do a talk show
I want to have some fun enjoy my life
but it's like enough of this this ever
encroaching movement on what we can say
and who's allowed to be on what platform
to say this or that and it's coming for
more and more people who are not bigots
or racists or anything even close to
that although I would defend bigots and
right racists right to speech as well
it's coming for people that just have
some thoughts that are a little bit
outside of sort of the leftist
progressive dogma that has just
completely taken over academia and
certainly everything going on in Silicon
Valley so so please do well for the next
two hours while we're here I'll give you
a shout out by name at Dave Rubin comm
sesh donate for five bucks and above 25
bucks in above monthly you're getting a
t-shirt 50 bucks above and monthly you
are getting a t-shirt and a mug which I
will sign right here for you and oh
quickly already we got some shout outs
James Megan Jeffrey David Beverly Holly
and John welcome aboard guys thank you
very much I do appreciate it
okay let's see so here's how I'm gonna
jump in with with some questions I'm
gonna start with questions from patrons
right now because you guys have been the
lifeblood of this thing and I see some
questions popping up there
first I admire you leaving do you do
they still have you on the front page I
guess a couple people were saying that
patreon was still using me as as someone
that they were publicizing on the front
page I don't know you know it's funny I
sort of had a love-hate relationship
with them this whole time because I
never truly felt they really wanted us
say the SAMS and the Jordans and the
Brett Weinstein's and me I never really
felt that they kind of wanted us on
there because they are a lefty Silicon
Valley thing so I don't know that
they're using me or not right now to
pimp out this stuff but you know they
never followed me on Twitter which
always really bothered me I was like I'm
making you guys a lot of money like what
are you doing anyway that's just like
silly little dribble okay so but the
point is we're gonna we're gonna stay on
there till January 15th and then that
day will we'll shut it down and also I
do want to address something you know I
saw a couple people say well Sam did the
right thing because you know he just
immediately deleted it and I think it's
worth mentioning that we all god bless
him for doing that god bless and the
atheists for doing that you know we all
have different considerations I have a
business here with several employees
actually the day that we found this out
I was in I had speaking either that
night or the night before I was in
Montana speaking at the University of
Wyoming and we had just sent a
part-timer one of our part-timers a
full-time employment contract so in the
midst of this I'm just committing to
another full-time person as I see all
this so we all just have different
considerations that were that we're
dealing with but I think we're doing the
right thing and by the way I also don't
begrudge any of the people that want to
stay on patreon and fight so I you know
I have plenty of friends that are gonna
I think do just that or at least doing
it at the moment say Brett Weinstein and
and Colin Moriarty and plenty of other
people it's like if you can stay and
fight and change them we can all have
different tactics on how we want to go
about this rope-a-dope I think some of
us leaving is probably good I think some
people trying to fight and stay in
change is probably good it's it's all
there shoutouts to Jason to wim2 Hakan
who is getting a t-shirt and a mug
that's right my man I'm gonna sign that
mug for you right now this is a reuben
select member mug that will never be
printed again because it was for pay
tree on it has been signed and it's
going to you my man
thank you very much okay let's see I'll
jump on another patreon one I see a lot
coming in on super chat too which is
great so I'll get to those will you have
the opportunity to pay through PayPal
yeah if you go to Dave Rubin comm /
donate you can just use a credit card or
you can use PayPal there and you're good
to go so I should address actually
that's a good point so look there's a
couple things happening here one of the
one of the parts of censorship that we
have to deal with is what's going on
with these tech companies are people
being shadow banned on Twitter are the
algorithms not showing certain videos
are people getting unsubscribed or all
of these things that you guys know all
about now then I say this all the time
these companies are allowed to do what
they want I would like them to sort of
uphold the principles of free speech
that I hold dear but I don't know that I
can force a private company to do that
now if they were doing shady things in
the boards of these companies the
shareholders of these companies found
out well now maybe there's some there
might be some legal issues there would
be some internal issues for sure
but I don't think that the government
coming in and breaking up these
companies is the right answer there
could be certain legal things within
that I'm not a lawyer that might have to
be looked at okay
now as far as the payment processor part
of this so that's that's just the speech
part of it right
that's how can people be on platforms
and be allowed to talk so it's like a
guy like Carl Benjamin it's like if this
guy isn't allowed to be on platforms
then probably you watching this and half
of the people you know and that may
include me can't be on these platforms
that's why this was important for
somebody to start standing up to some of
this stuff the next level of this though
is so we have to deal with the platforms
themselves who can be on platforms and
what are you allowed to do on these
platforms and they can all have
different Terms of Service
should-should future platforms maybe
only have to obey the laws of the land
so anyone can say whatever they want
except you can't make say a direct
threat or you can't do a you know a fire
alarm in a movie theater type thing or
you know inspire a terrorist attack
something like that or call for a
terrorist attack that would be an
interesting way to do it should a Terms
of Service have more to do with the
statement of principles that the
University of Chicago has
defending free speech possibly so all of
these things have to be dealt with and
thought about and all of that the other
part of this issue though is the payment
processor part of this because it turns
out now and this is very annoying
because nobody wants to fight MasterCard
and Visa and the rest of it I assure you
I don't that you can catch there is
there is a tweet that at one time over
the summer I think it was in August that
patreon tweeted to Robert Spencer who is
a not Richard Spencer the alt-right guy
Robert Spencer who is a New York Times
bestselling author now he happens to
write a lot about Islam but he's a New
York Times bestselling author they
tweeted to him that they had to close
their account and they said
unfortunately because of pressure from
MasterCard
so now it's like wait a minute uh are we
gonna be policing speech to the point
that people won't even be able to make
money that people will not be able to
exchange in in commerce and in goods
well now we've really ramped this thing
up so these are major major major things
that people better start thinking about
that I know you watching this are
thinking about but everyone better start
thinking about these things before it's
too late okay couple shoutouts Jacob
Raquel Earl and Edward Sean Glen Joe
Jeffrey Taylor Taylor's getting a mug
I'm signing that mug for Taylor right
now what did I do with this with the
marker here we go
Thank You Taylor I appreciate that
you're getting a mug my friend and
Morgan's getting a mug all right Morgan
here we go
and guys I truly I just want to be clear
first off I just want to be clear about
how how truly appreciative of your
support I am like you guys make this
thing go like if you believe in
resetting some of the national
conversation into something decent if
you believe that we can actually change
the world through ideas as I believe
you're supporting the show because
hopefully this gets out to more people
and I can promise you that it is like
trust me I just did this world tour with
Jordan where we're gonna continue this
and it would probably another 40 or 50
stops in the spring and we're doing
about 10 stops in Australia in February
and it's like everywhere we went every
Airport I went whether it was in
Helsinki or Stockholm or Copenhagen or
Dublin it's like people were coming up
to us and it's like there's
something happened here like something
good really is happening and people want
to stand up for what they believe in and
people want to fight for ideas that they
care about and people want to know more
and not be like bludgeoned by the
mainstream media that makes everyone
dumb and not be called a racist every
time you say something that's slightly
out of what mainstream can accept so I
truly you you've I mean in the statement
that I wrote that we released to our
patrons you guys have quite literally
made my dreams come true because I'm
doing what I'm supposed to be doing and
I had a you know I can't possibly more
be more appreciative of that okay hey
Dave if the social justice warrior
ideology has infected Visa and
MasterCard and can cut funding or
services to whomever they please what
legal recourse is there if there are no
alternatives it's downright disturbing
for it to have come to this okay so as I
said I'm not a lawyer but there are
lawyers looking into some of this stuff
I look they have their own agreements
like when you sign up for a credit card
you sign some crazy agreement that
nobody has a lawyer sitting there with
so can these companies do what they want
there's probably some there there is
relationships with government agencies
related to these companies so there's
probably something to look at there I
would say and you know I'm hearing a lot
of this especially on Twitter is that
maybe the end game of all of this is
that the only way to truly truly be a
free creator now whatever that means
whatever you create so in this case
creating video and audio content is that
you would be posting it on the
blockchain and also doing all your
financial transactions on the blockchain
through Bitcoin and aetherium and
litecoin and everything else we're
learning about it I have a zillion
meetings tomorrow basically all day long
tomorrow I'm gonna be talking to crypto
people and we're trying to figure out
all that so by right now by closing
patreon I'm doing it to remove a
middleman and do something that I just
think is the right thing to do we're
pushing everybody to our website which
doesn't solve the long long term
problems if payment processors come for
us and things like that but think how
crazy this conversation is like I'm I
actually have to entertain the idea that
payment processors could come for me or
anyone in my crew that you know of or
come for you like how crazy is
that's crazy like we're not doing
something evil and twisted here you know
I mean we're doing actually what you're
supposed to do in a free society which
is talk about things so switching
everybody over doesn't solve the long
long term problem but we're also as I
discussed with Jordan and you can watch
the two videos that are on our Channel
and on Jordan's channel we're working on
some technological answers to this I
think that there may be multi multi
pronged and sort of multi-layered
versions of how we're gonna put all of
this out that maybe some you know maybe
we'll have everything on the traditional
platforms and be putting up everything
on blockchain I mean there there's all
sorts of ways we're trying to hit this
and trust me the amount of people that
have reached out to me that work at
Google that work at Facebook that work
at Yahoo that are tech startup people
that are just regular folks in the
middle of nowhere it's like man people
see an opportunity here and this is what
freedom is all about right someone is
going to solve this I hope that I'm part
of it right like I hope the right thing
comes across you or the right idea pops
and it's like I'm part of the thing that
solves this but if you watching this
right now if you can solve this freaking
thing I'll join you on that platform
like let's figure this thing out
together okay shoutouts
Alex Christine Brian Jenna Christopher
Paige Michael James Neil thank you guys
Neil in California he's getting a mug
I'm gonna do that right now also drew
and Glen are getting mugs thank you guys
I sign that one already so okay there we
go that's for Neil where's this one hold
on I got I'm gonna need more mugs this
is for Glen there you go brother thank
you very much and one more all right
there you go you're getting the full
Dave Rubin signature right there you
know the other piece of this thing
that's interesting is that you know
everyone as I said everyone has
different considerations everyone does
things differently so like I've had all
these networks reaching out to me I
don't want to name them right now but
they're I know right now that there are
a couple of different networks that are
sort of vying for me to join them the
fact that I can make my own schedule
that you know in December we basically
pre
I think we did some of the best shows
we've ever done in December most of them
were pre-taped because I had done all
sorts of travel with Jordan and we're
doing more travel like we're gonna try
to do some more stuff on the road like I
can make every decision that I think is
right because of the freedom that you
guys are afforded me so please don't
think that that is lost on me because
it's it's awesome have I talked to
Sargon lately we've traded a couple
emails and I think at some point we'll
probably do a Skype chat but we were
sort of waiting for a little bit of the
dust to settle here and we'll figure it
out so yes we will we will do something
with him any information on professed
goals to develop slash back an
alternative platform as well as a
funding strategy for said product so I
can't get into all of this right now
suffice to say that as when I discuss
with Jordan we are working on something
he was building out something already
that had some of the the technological
needs that we would need for a patreon
like platform but there's all sorts of
questions here like I will be very
honest with you guys is the idea that we
should be building a platform that
absolutely everyone should be on that
then becomes the home of all sorts of
nefarious activities and bad people now
that let's say it's within the realm of
legality at least right like okay I in
principle I can get there but it's like
do I want to be the leader of that
platform and also when it gets to the
moment where there has to be actual
gatekeeping where somebody does
something that's really bananas it's
like do I want to be the guy or do I
want to be on the board of the group
that has to make the decision to boot
people like I don't know that that's
exactly for me but again this is why
blockchain might resolve some of these
things so we'll figure out some of that
okay couple other shoutouts
Angelo Adam John and John and Ian and a
couple more mugs Peter drew and
Christian I'm gonna need more bugs guys
we're running low on mugs here we only
put about 20 here to start okay we've
got that one that one drew there you go
my man and I'm gonna need another mug
for Christian okay here we go
just subscribe Dave Rubin comm donate
for 25 bucks a month keep up the
excellent work and the good fight you
got it my friend thank you for your hard
work and putting your principles
ahead of the money let me just address
that quick because I I said this before
you can just toss him out or again I
said this before but you know it's funny
like so in the last couple weeks our
patreon but we got on patreon as I said
in in June of 2016
patreon was mostly like video gamers and
some other interesting creators but not
a lot of political people I think I was
really one of the first if not the first
from sort of the more political free
speech space to get on there and then
once I got in there that sort of broke
the dam and then then a whole bunch of
other people that on we got to our
original funding goal I think we
originally asked for it for 20 grand a
month eventually we moved that up to 30
grand a month that helped me literally
buy this house build this studio we've
we've been able to redo the studio hire
full-time as part-timers all of those
things because of you guys but what I
was also realizing along the road was
that why back you know it's not even
what I was realizing basically was it's
like having even if this was all going
great why shouldn't we absolutely
control why everything we're doing why
not take that last step to sort of true
independence so all right let's see hey
Dave as much as I hate the idea of
government intervention is it time for
the government to look into the deep
platforming issue or is that too much of
a slippery slope I think this is this
might be the digital conversation to
have in 2019 as I said in the video with
Jordan what kind of internet do you want
what kind of ability to communicate with
other people do you want we're gonna
really have to start thinking about it
now look from a libertarian perspective
the idea that the government would come
in and and break up these companies or
force them to do anything it makes no
sense from a libertarian perspective
from a classical liberal perspective
where you you're more ok with a light
touch of the government there could be
some argument that makes sense certainly
from a more conservative argument
conservatives generally are
anti-government but then are okay often
with breaking up monopolies and things
like that ok there is now from a lefty
perspective you'd love to have the
government involved in everything my
feelings still right now even though I'm
right in the thick of this thing and it
would be nice to have like
you know some superpower just come in
and fix the whole damn thing is that I
believe in human ingenuity this problem
will be solved there are people watching
this I have no doubt there are people
watching this that work at Google at
work at all of these companies that want
to solve these things I don't think
everyone is a social justice warrior I
don't think everyone wants to be this
hysterical preening morally monster that
is writing these terms of services that
is deciding who can speak and who won't
speak in all of these things so I think
that I think that ingenuity is the way
to do it
there's always an argument to be made
that the government should jump in and
do these things and I just think that
thus if you give the government more
power right you give the government more
power the government does not give that
power back so you have to be very very
very careful that said look Prager you
sued YouTube over restricting their
videos I love Dennis Prager we I think
just have a difference of opinion on
that and that that's just how it is all
right I got some more mugs here so here
we go Stephen and Kenny you're getting
mugs thank you guys very much I
appreciate it
that's for you Stephen there you go
brother and Kenny you're getting a mug
there we go all right and you're getting
a t-shirt too super chat thanks Dave you
got it love the show all right love Dave
and the ID doubles civil discourse among
people with disparate ideas why not
right I'm getting a lot of thank-yous
here there's a lot of thank-yous but I
want to get to some questions do you
think you and Jordan will make a big
enough dent to patreon if they're forced
to change their ways because of the exit
pegs it who would you return so this is
interesting so look when we started this
thing when this thing all hit at the
beginning of December I think we were at
that point we were making around 30
grand a month on patreon now of course
that sounds like a lot of money right so
30 grand a month times 12 months we're
looking at about 400
no it's 300 360 grand a year something
like that right now that is obviously a
lot of money now when I tell you that I
have employees and mortgages and
insurance and all that other nonsense to
make a business it's actually not that
much money but I'm not sitting here
complaining and this is in Crimea
River or anything like that now there
they get a small whatever was they get
let's say 5% of that or something like
that and then some other fees on top of
that Jordan I don't know exactly what he
was making per month but I know I know
it was more than that Sam was probably
in that category as well is is are all
of us leaving and whoever else is
leaving I think Tim Poole left I think
some other people are planning on
leaving or all of us leaving gonna cause
enough of a dent in their finances to
have them turn around now if I'm not
mistaken but someone can check on this
patreon got about 450 million dollars in
VC funding in the last like year or two
so let's say we cause them to lose a
couple hundred grand or even a couple
million this year and and people are
really pissed at them do they if they
really have just bought into social
justice and bought into this this
language control and all of this
nonsense it's like a couple million
bucks probably doesn't hurt them at all
and if anything the people who are
funding them might be thrilled that
they're getting us off these platforms
so that's why I think it's completely
legit for some people to say I'm gonna
stay here and fight and for some people
to go it's like any other movement of
any time right Malcolm X and Martin
Luther King jr. didn't agree on every
tactic and I'm in no way comparing us to
them but you know II mean like this is
just how things how every battle is
fought you have people that want to be
more aggressive you have people that
want to change things from the inside
you have people that want to leave and
come from the outside you have all of
those different dynamics so we're all
gonna try look the fact that nobody's
from from patreon has reached out to me
nobody's reached out to Jordan I don't
think anyone reached out to Sam I think
in a weird way they're mostly probably
happy that we're going but that doesn't
mean it's a reason to stay I think you
just you got to do what you think is
right I really do believe that what are
your options after patreon and so as I
said at the moment we want to shift as
many of you guys to monthly donations at
Dave Rubin comm / donate which by the
way we're taking we're taking Bitcoin
there as well and then the hope is that
we will solve the long-term problem
which i think is probably a crypto
answer but in the meantime there are
many other ways of doing subscription
things we're gonna try to figure out I
mean I know one of the reasons that
people loved patreon was you had access
to an ad-free version of the podcast so
we're gonna look into that we're gonna
look into a couple other things related
to what what
there are things we can do for you guys
but at the moment it's about getting
everybody just getting everybody to move
over and then hopefully whatever we
build on the other side of that we'll be
able to just flip the the info so like
so stripe is the payment processor we're
using I think they're pretty decent and
I think that they're they're gonna offer
us some protections and that hopefully
what we build after we'd be able to fold
in the info that we have from you guys
on stripe into the next thing okay what
will you do if Richard Spencer or David
Duke signs up as a creator on your
platform will you remove them or leave
them on so this is so first off this is
about the the thing that Jordan and I
are working on we are working through
all of these problems we are trying to
decide if this should be an invite-only
platform or should it be up to everybody
as I said before there are major issues
related to Terms of Service and all of
these things so I don't want to comment
on that specifically yet because it
would be because it's being worked out
at the moment I think you know me I
think you guys know me well enough that
I will do everything I can to defend
everyone's right to be able to say what
they want that does not mean there
aren't going to be consequences and I
also believe that private companies can
do what they want there is the question
of platform versus publisher here which
is really interesting as I said in the
thing with Jordan the other day to
loosely quote Eric Weinstein should
conservatives be allowed to drive on
public roads I mean at some point should
conservatives or conservatives or anyone
that's outside of the mainstream should
they be allowed to have access to
telephones and running water at their
house and all of these things because
that's how important these modes of
communication these platforms are it's
like this is your your way to connect
with the world and if they're allowed to
say you can't connect with the world
well what else are they allowed to to
hold off on you on so it's it's a lot to
think about it it's a lot to think about
for sure all right let me jump back in
we've got a lot of shout outs here
Trevor Lucas Patrick Jeffery
conservative Mexican Henry John Chris
Patricia another Jeffrey Roy Milko
Arthur Rick Bert Alexander Vicki John
Robert Luke Ross dag fan Ernie Thomas
Shawn rod and Nicholas thank you guys
for donating while we're doing this just
a reminder in case
you're just jumping in if you donated
Dave Rubin comm / donate for 25 bucks
monthly you're gonna get the Reuben
report shirt there's only about 200 of
these left on earth they will never be
made again because these were the the
patreon shirts that we were given to our
patrons so since we're leaving patreon
we're not going to print any more of
these and if you do fifty dollars and
above monthly on on dave rubin consurtio
you're gonna get the shirt and i'm gonna
sign a mug for you right here okay
Timothy and Bonnie thank you guys
let's see hi Dave I appreciate how
thoughtful you've been with your
decision to leave patreon I agree with
you that there's a solution to the deep
platforming issue on patreon and other
sites have you seen today's headline
about Makayla Peterson's brief
suspension from YouTube so I did see
that so Jordan loop me and I know
Makayla obviously through Jordan Mikayla
is Jordans daughter Mikayla has a
YouTube channel and has been a big
proponent of the carnivore diet which
she I don't want to I don't want to
misquote her at all here but she
basically has been eating exclusively
red meat and it has solves a lot of her
health problems she had all sorts of
health problems I think rheumatoid
arthritis and a whole bunch of other
things and through this diet it is
seriously helped her she's been on Joe
Rogan talking about it and a whole bunch
of other things her channel got a strike
two days ago or it might have even been
yesterday and she was gonna have she was
gonna be temporarily banned or something
for three months and of course YouTube
doesn't know why so again or doesn't
tell you why and this is why all of this
is so tough to deal with so even me
right now so we're about to cross a
million subscribers obviously the show
is doing incredibly well last month was
I think our second or third best month
and subscribers and views and all that
stuff I don't even have a personal
contact at YouTube
I have no if I have a problem at YouTube
I have to fill out a generic form that
they just send you some robotic answer
back I don't even have an email or a
name of someone at YouTube to contact
like that's the problem these companies
have become so big that they they
operate as sort of monolithic
governments now again do I think that
the government coming in and breaking up
those companies will somehow make them
better do I think the government that
doesn't really understand technology if
they could only break up
technology companies would make any of
this better or if government regulators
had to come in and audit YouTube every
now and again and say you know you have
to give Dave Rubin a personal contractor
but it's like I don't think any of that
is the answer but I think by talking
about these issues this is the funny
thing you see this all the time when
when you talk about that competition is
the answer then you'll see all these
people that'll be like Oh seeing you
free-market people you don't want the
government involved you're not allowed
to complain and it's like no you're
supposed to that's what you do in a free
society you exercise your freedom to
hopefully change things for the better
which is exactly what we're doing here
ok shoutouts to Anthony Andrew Robert
Chris and Laurie and conservative
Mexican he just upgraded his mug status
so I'm gonna sign him a mug thank you
conservative Mexican I you know I got to
tell you guys since since your name is
conservative Mexican there I have met a
lot of conservative Mexicans in the last
year that I did not really know we're
out there either have my stand-up shows
or at the the Petersen shows I've met a
lot of not only Mexicans I've met a lot
of conservative Latino people oh and
actually speaking of stand-up if you're
in Ontario California which is Southern
Cali about half hour 45 minutes from LA
I will be there on january 9th doing
stand-up and then a live sit-down with
with Bret Weinstein on January 9th and
on January 30th I will be an Irvine
County or I will be an Irvine which is
in Orange County California and there
will be a surprise IDW guest with there
with me there too the stand-up shows
have just been great like I'm getting
back to my roots I promise you as a
stand-up show like you have not seen
it's sort of just a free-for-all I just
sort of do a town hall I tell a couple
of jokes but I'm just messing around
with the crowd I give stuff away and
it's completely politically incorrect
and we're just having a ball and I think
you'll enjoy it Robert you're getting a
mug here you go Robert thank you very
much okay I thought that was a
particularly good signature here we go
let's see man there's a zillion look at
this question is just flying in here hey
Dave will there be a video slash
livestream of you shutting down the
patreon account on the 15th so we've
been discussing that I actually think it
would be pretty cool
if I have my laptop and I literally just
like walk up to the camera over there
and press Delete so we have a whole
bunch of scheduling things going on
January is completely bananas because
I'm gonna be in Australia for most of
February so we're taping a ton of stuff
in January so that we have content
obviously for February but I think we'll
probably do that I want to make sure
that there aren't technical reasons why
we couldn't do that but yes I think
we're gonna try to do that thanks for
stepping up and being a leader in this
freedom of speech and helping us all
have a voice you know I have nothing
better to do that's really the truth why
have you enjoyed not performing Germany
yet 2019 yeah I think we're gonna be in
Germany either in May or June we're
working out the rest of that European
tour
let's see holy cow there's a lot here
how can we get in on the beta test
version of your and JP's patreon
alternative I think there will be an
answer to that probably within the next
month or so I think they'll probably end
up being a landing page and sort of an
invite-only to the beta so hang tight on
that I mean it's not just not only do
you have to build tech and solve these
problems and address Terms of Service
it's like there's a whole bunch other
stuff you've got to figure out about
branding we got a business to build like
there's a million a million million
things so I think our one sort of slight
mistake was that in the first video that
I did with Jordan Jordan said that he
was gonna try or thought it was possible
that maybe we could get it out by
December 25th or January 1st that was
probably a little bit over-ambitious
just because we really wanted to solve a
problem so it was like holy cow can we
do this quick and just just get some
bare-bones thing up and then when we
really thought about it's like you
really do have to be methodical and you
want to make sure that all of those
pressure points that you can be taken
down on either technologically or
because of the mob or everything else
are because the media is gonna come
after you you want to make sure that
you're covering all your bases here so
we are covering our bases I promise you
that Ben are you ready for a mug
I'm sending you a mug thank you Ben all
right there you go I'm gonna need more
mugs guys and you're getting a t-shirt
to everyone that gets a mug gets a
t-shirt Dave Rubin calm slash donate is
where you're gonna do that
super chat happy new year thank you very
much
I absolutely love your show how do I get
my wife to watch your show and you put
that part in caps I like that that's
funny you know I get a lot of messages
from people that are having problems I
get messages from people that are
getting divorced over politics because
it's you usually not always the case is
that the the woman is a lefty sjw the
whole thing and that the man has been
trying to you know show her some of
these videos or just break her out of
that mindset it's not always that way
with the female on one side of the male
on the other but I've literally got
messages of people that are getting
divorced over politics which is sad and
it's also like that's why not everything
should be political and it's why if you
look at my Twitter I don't tweet about
the political machinations every day I
don't think I've tweeted once about the
government shutdown it's like politics
is starting to become incredibly boring
to me what what is interesting to me is
what is happening culturally and what is
happening with the way we relate with
the way we relate to government with the
way we relate to these platforms and the
way we relate to conversation and our
ability to communicate with each other
that is really interesting to me
the little machinations of politics it's
like man you've got you've got half the
country that that says Trump is Hitler
which is so absolutely bananas
ridiculous and at the same time their
answer is they always want more
government and it's like no you should
always want to strip the power away so
that when it's somebody you don't like
they don't have a lot of power and then
the trade-off is when it's somebody you
do like maybe they can't get everything
done that you want in your utopian
society okay shoutouts null L Therese
Mike II Wayne Christian Linda Mike Chris
Peter Nicholas and Paul thank you all
guys very much I really do appreciate it
okay a lot of people are saying that I
should delete the the patreon account
online so maybe I'll do it I'll just
bust out the laptop and just do it in
front of you guys that would actually be
pretty fun there's a lot of super chats
coming in I'm trying to try to read them
here
let's see freedom of speech is worth a
bit of inconvenience close my patreon
account after January 1st Auto payments
and also PayPal since they're complicit
well look this is this is the payment
processor thing and I'm bulimia I did
not know what tremenda
I'm out about payment processing until
the last couple weeks and there are
certain payment processors that are a
little more willing to stand up to the
mob some of them are it if an entire
company has been sort of infected by by
the progressive Dogma then they're gonna
drop anybody at the first sign of
trouble so we're talking to all sorts of
people as I said yes tomorrow I have a
just an insane day basically from 8 a.m.
to the end of the day just taking calls
and taking video chats with all sorts of
people that think they have solutions
and so now it's like I've got like an as
if I wasn't busy enough between the tour
and I'm writing the book and I'm doing
the show and do it stand-up it's like
now I have this alternate job as like a
as like a tech guy which is quite
bizarre but life is strange let's see
I'm a strong conservative that has
changed some of my beliefs because your
show well I appreciate that you know
it's it's cool you know it's funny there
was this um this data in society
ridiculous report that was funded by
some soros group doesn't matter that did
all this this whole thing about how
YouTube is converting people into the
all right and they somehow connected
they just use lines to connect people
that have talked to each other so I'm
connected to Joe Rogan and this guy is
connected to Tim Poole this guy is
connected to Sam Harris and this guy is
connected to this and it's like there
was no methodology behind it of course
as recline at Vox tweets out how
important of a study it is and all this
endless [ __ ] and BuzzFeed does
pieces on and the rest of it and the
whole idea being that we're that you're
watching this show that you person
watching this right now are watching
this show you're watching the
conversations that I have listening to
the things that I talk about or my
guests talk about and somehow you're
being radicalized to the alt-right
that you're hearing about the individual
and that we should treat people as
individuals and treat everybody equally
and should not be racist and we should
not be prejudiced and all of these
things and that's somehow that's turning
you all to right
of course it's dribble there was
actually Tim Poole did a video on this
there was a guy who recently did a true
analysis of a lot of these channels and
it turns out in many cases when you
people watch these shows you have people
that are hard more hardcore right let's
say that are actually shifting a little
bit more liberal it's all just drivel
but I will tell you this that the focus
you know it's why why is there so much
focus BuzzFeed and Vox and New York
Times and the rest of these things why
are they
focusing unlike this little crew of
youtubers why do they want to take down
PewDiePie so badly well it's like people
are actually watching this people are
watching this and those companies
they're just funded to the tilts but
they're they're dying there dot they're
dinosaurs that should die and hopefully
something better will be will come after
them so there you go alright shoutouts
to Thomas Robert Robert and Irma and
Dana you're getting a bug sister I'm
gonna sign it right here there you go
there you go you know what I will also
offer up I don't know if I was gonna get
in trouble for doing this but you know
when we when we flipped our set when we
this past September we have most of our
old set we've got the chairs from our
old set I need to hang onto the right
chair because I still use it when I do
the the three-way conversation but we've
got two of the guest chairs that my
guests were always sitting and you may
remember those aqua chairs and we've got
the old table the old coffee table so I
would say make us an offer that we can't
refuse and maybe we can get you one of
those if you want one of those that
would be a logistical nightmare probably
in a shipping ridiculousness but let's
see okay um the left doesn't care now
that they control the media and the
internet platform company companies if
you want to know how they react when
they are on the other side of the coin
see the 1960s freedom of speech is our
right regardless of which side you were
on and Dave and Jordan are right what is
going on is very ominous and Orwellian
well well look I agree both sides can
can be pretty bad when it comes to
speech remember it was the right that
used to be all about video game violence
right that video games are causing
violence and they should have warnings
and shouldn't be sold and they were
gonna boycott stores and all of these
things so this is not necessarily our
left-right issue and again we talk about
this all the time but this is also one
of those things where it's like the
left-right paradigm is just becoming
increasingly meaningless because you're
either basically libertarian and that
you're sort of that you're for personal
freedom which can be a little bit messy
because that means someone else is gonna
have personal freedom too and they might
be doing something you don't like or you
want central planning you want state
control over things I think you guys
know where I fall out on that what I
would say is
that we want to build something that
will be as open as possible that will
also be protected from I mean I've said
this port it'll be protected from the
mob it will be technologically sensible
and it will offer some answers to some
of these things there's a little bit
more that I could tell you that we've
accomplished already but I just can't
quite get into all that and I wish I
could okay
conservative Mexican he's back can I
pick up my mug and shirt when I see you
at CSUF I met you at the improv in
Irvine yeah you know what we'll make
that happen guys can you make a note of
that conservative Mexican we're gonna
we're gonna bring him the shirt when I
do that show on January 29th which that
reminds me
January 9th I'm at Ontario improv down
here in Southern Cali Brett Weinstein is
gonna be joining me for that when I do
about an hour then Brett will join me
for about an hour
live sit-down January 30th I'm at Irvine
California with an undisclosed member of
the intellectual dark web and on that
CSUF Cal State on January 29th which is
a college gig but they are selling
tickets to the public on that too okay
what the hell are we doing here a little
radio reset for you we are leaving
patreon on January 15th that's it that's
it they don't want to respect free
speech you got to stand up sometimes in
life it's weird I'm watching my monthly
revenue drop like hell and and I'm
getting emails from people that are
inspiring me so it's a little bizarre if
you go to Dave Rubin calm slash donate
we are gonna send you a mug and a
t-shirt if you jump in for $50 and above
and I'll sign the mug right here for you
if you do that at a monthly level 25
bucks you're getting the limited never
going to be printed again because they
were just for patreon t-shirts whoa
that's a lot of talking okay and five
bucks and above and I'm just gonna give
you a shout out right here so I'm gonna
give a shout out to Jacob to William and
to Garrett and Aaron Lawrence and
Ricardo you guys are getting mugs and
that's running out of mugs again all
right here we go there we go and Mamma
Mia keep the questions coming guys I'm
seeing all these and I'm I promise you
I'm gonna get to as many as possible
okay this is real right this is real and
it's raw that's what I can tell you guys
let's see I seriously hope I can
continue to listen to you and many
others that I do I think it was positive
that you're taking a pre-emptive step
versus waiting for the axe to fall
assuming that it does well that's
interesting so what I can tell you is
this so if you think about sort of the
whole idea crew whatever that actually
means to you but let's say this group of
twenty or thirty or so people I can tell
you that the the sargon thing by Sargon
getting booted everyone realized even
though some of the people have never met
him some of the people didn't know who
he was there were several people who
didn't even know anything about him
everybody was like this this one is just
you know in life you don't get the
perfect opportunity the second you want
it you know what I mean you're either
gonna swing early sometimes and
sometimes you're gonna swing too late
but sometimes you just got a swing and I
think what I realized that least for
this one was it was like not only
because as I said to you earlier when I
started waking up to some of these ideas
Sargon was someone that was doing this
on YouTube and although I don't know
everything about him and and truth be
told I don't think I've watched a video
of his in a year I've just been
extremely busy I know that he's
basically a decent human and I know that
he's not all trite and I know that he's
been fighting the forces of racism and
the rest of it and it's like we could
just sit quietly right like we could
like the chances I suppose well I think
some of you would disagree with me on
this but I think the chances that
they're gonna come for me let's say in
the next couple weeks or a couple months
are pretty slim right like basically
because that would be such a massive
movement line that it would be bananas
but we just saw a massive move of the
line so it's like we just don't know
when it's gonna happen and and you don't
get that perfect moment so maybe Sargon
is the perfect case here that everyone's
gonna jump aboard and defend Jordan and
I felt it was the right one and and here
we are okay let's see would you have
tried to launch this new platform if
PayPal stripe MasterCard etc had not cut
off patreon competition subscribe star
that was big so you know it's
interesting when this whole thing
happened subscribe star sort of came out
of nowhere and everybody was like we
you've got a jump on subscribe star it's
the patreon alternative and what I kept
saying everybody and this was before I
was
discussing with Jordan about doing a an
alternative platform alternative
platform was that just jumping to
another site even if their intentions
are good is just a it's just a little
stopgap like this is a frog in a pot
that is slowly boiling and the Frog
doesn't know when it's gonna be dead
that's sort of where we're at at the
moment so just jumping this has nothing
to do with the people that subscribe
star or any of that but it was just
gonna jump to sort of an earlier version
of patreon which then let's say in a
year from now if it had gone
successfully would have had all of the
problems of a patreon so that's why I
didn't want to do subscribe star I
suppose right now if subscribe star had
not had I guess it was stripe and PayPal
and MasterCard and whoever else if they
had not cut them off then I think there
would be a little more legitimacy behind
what subscribe star is doing but that's
why I'm saying this is a massive
technological problem that perhaps can
only be solved by blockchain and in the
meantime if we can just remove as many
middlemen as possible
for all that you guys see that's another
interesting thing is that there's a real
generational shift here we know that
most of the people that watch these
videos on YouTube are younger younger
people are more willing to spend their
hard-earned dollars supporting people
that care about the things that they
care about so like back in the day I'm
not that old I'm 42 for most of my life
you had bundled cable so let's say you
only wanted to watch ABC NBC ESPN and
TNT well you that wasn't a package you
couldn't just pay a couple bucks for
each of those and get that they forced
you to buy a bundle basically so you'd
end up with lifetime and we Channel and
Comedy Central and a zillion other
things that maybe you'd never want it
and that's the only way you did it as
that model crumbles and it's so
interesting because we're watching
television model crumble the Cable model
crumble as we're watching mainstream
media crumble as we're watching the
political establishment crumble we're
watching all this happen at once but as
that crumbles people are going oh I
don't have to spend say a hundred twenty
bucks on cable a month anymore I could
spend say 40 bucks a month and I could
give me that up amongst eight creators
that I like give them five bucks each
and if enough people do that all of
these people that care about the things
that I care about will be able to go on
and live and hopefully do more and
and all of those things so there's also
an interesting age thing happening here
and and it's very cool to be part of
truly okay let's jump back to shoutouts
Andy Andy Drew Zachary Camille Michael
thank you guys and we got some more mugs
todd and peter with addy he's on there
and Brandon thank you guys so you guys
are getting mugs that I'm signing right
now signing the mugs right now you guys
are getting t-shirts that we'll get out
to you as soon as possible and the last
one there was for for Brendon thanks man
appreciate it it's cool right like it's
it's actually the other thing that it
was so interesting just on a personal
note you know this year this past year
2018 was definitely without question it
was the most rewarding of my life
personally professionally on every front
the work that I'm doing I think is
important and good it's it's brought a
certain level of happiness and success
to my life which is great going on this
tour with Jordan where we did about a
hundred stops in all sorts of different
countries and went all over the United
States and as I said we're gonna extend
it now into into Australia and for
February and then we're doing all these
European stops and meeting all of you
guys like that's the thing it's like I
know that online it seems like an
endless hate fest and and it often is
and it's we're owning the Lib tards and
the Cox herbs and all this nonsense but
it's like there are good people
everywhere and I saw them and I see them
every single night one of the things
that we do at the at the Jordan shows he
does a meet and greet after and I do it
mean right now for Jordans meet and
greet obviously it's the it's Jordans
show so he gets let's say 300 people
that go to his meet and green you get a
picture with him and he does a little
talk minor are usually somewhere between
like say 20 and 50 people and it's
really cool because we go into a private
room or sometimes there's like a bar
area at the theater and we get to chat
like I sit around we try to get the the
chairs in a circle and we sit around and
I get to hear from people about their
concerns or what's what they're excited
about or whatever it is and they ask me
questions sometimes I ask them questions
I know
people meet after we've been we've been
meeting people that are startin IDW
groups people are hanging out after
sometimes at some of the shows there are
people that hand out flyers and they're
like if you want to talk about some of
these ideas afterwards meet us at the
bar down the block and I've gone to one
or two of them actually at the we did
two shows in Stockholm which were two of
my favorite shows then I loved loved
loved loved in nordic countries but
stockholm particularly and we did my
meet-and-greet there were a ton about it
like 60 people that we were jammed in
this little room and then I was like you
know what why don't we just wrap this
thing up early and go to a bar and then
like 60 of us went to a bar
Aaron flam was there who's a comedian
from Sweden who's been on the show and a
couple other influential people there
shoutouts to our s Derek Laura and
Joseph thank you guys very much and a
mug and a t-shirt for Dylan thank you
brother I already signed that one guys
I'm gonna need more mugs yeah so lots of
lots of cool stuff happening guys there
you go that is the Dave Rubin mug I'm
running out of room at the table here
okay if MasterCard or other payment
companies can prevent me from supporting
the artists or makers who are engaging
in legal activities that I prefer
there's no limit to what they control
it's definitely a big issue and I think
the left doesn't understand how giving
this type of power to a corporation can
swing background on them have you
reached out to MasterCard so that
harkens back to an earlier question one
of the one of the reasons that this is
so crazy
is that so think about it you've got
half whatever it is this certain set of
people that think Trump is the
Antichrist or is Hitler or any of this
nonsense
but generally speaking people on the
right generally speaking right if you're
generally speaking a conservative or
libertarian doesn't want to use state
power to accomplish their goals they
want the market and individual people to
solve things now on the left they
believe that state power is the answer
to most things Bernie believes that
state power is the answer to most things
Elizabeth Warren believes this Kamala
Harris believes this is what what 99% of
progressives believe now obviously I
don't agree with that but let's give
them benefited out that sometimes the
government can do some good things okay
sure the government has done some good
things by the way well I mean if you
want to watch really interesting
interview I talked about this with Peter
teal and then he said at some point it
just stopped working he said I he said
something to the effect of I'd have no
reason
libertarian if any of it worked but what
the real scary part of what's happening
right now is it's like okay so let's say
we give the power let's say the
conservatives and libertarians are like
you know what this deep platforming
thing is so dangerous and and it's
because it's coming after us we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna shave away on
our ideals and you know what the
government can get involved this one
time because Google controls so much
information the government can do at
this one time well what happens then
when let's say Trump is out and now
you've got a progressive in the White
House who believes the government
controlling now you've just given the
control of the platforms to people who
are even more politically against you
and have more power so this is why
everyone has to be very careful and why
once again I would still say this is
about ingenuity of the American people
okay let's see a hundred bucks on super
chat keep up the good work great work
thank you I will do that
Thank You penny thank you Andrew Thank
You Leslie Thank You Donald and a mug
for Tignes you got it here we go man I
wish we could move the camera a little
because I am surrounded by mugs right
now this is pretty crazy okay hey Dave
what about Maxine Bernier is there an
interview coming soon love the show keep
up the great work
yeah we've got a Maxine dernier is a
libertarian up in Canada which you know
that the government has gone completely
out of control if libertarians are
gaining steam in Canada we've got him
via Skype
I believe it's next week maybe a week or
two but we are doing that I'm looking
forward to doing that one let's see I
love you so much for the stance you're
making no tolerance for censorship I
love you too thank you for taking a
stand against censorship and providing
exceptional content you got it hey Dave
huge fan here what things did patreon do
well that you guys want to nail down in
this new platform also can you tell us
everything new about it we didn't
previously know have a great day so I
can't give you all the specifics on what
we're trying to do and a lot of it still
is Amorphis and believe me we're
bringing in a lot of the voices that
you'd think we'd bring in and we're
bringing in some voices that maybe you
wouldn't think we'd bring in what what
did patreon do well look they were the
first one that solved a massive problem
there was a problem that creators could
not figure out a way to make a living
despite making good
on YouTube the the CPM is meaning the
cost per thousand views that the ads the
advertisers were paying out is extremely
low on YouTube it's something like 2
bucks per thousand views then there was
the heat the whole D monetization issue
which by the way is still real so
although generally speaking it's gotten
better for our channel you know right
before Christmas who do I have on right
before Christmas why I did a show with
Rabbi David Wolpe from Temple Sinai here
in Los Angeles and he was sitting in
that chair and I and this chair was
Bishop Aaron from the archdiocese here
in LA
that was monetized what was the show
that I had on earlier in the week just
two days before it was Imam - IDI they
did not they D monetize that one by not
only the algorithm D monetized it but
then manual review so I can talk to a
rabbi and a priest monetized I could
talk to an imam not monta it's like it's
just all bananas and subjective so
patreon what did they do well they were
the first one that said let's find
another way that creators can come
together in one spot and people who are
interested in creators would have some
discoveries so maybe you'd go on there
let's say you were you were a orden
peterson fan you might go on there you
might donate five bucks a month to
Jordan and then you might look around
and I think they had like a sort of
related channels kind of thing you might
go you know what I've got 20 extra bucks
a month or I'm gonna drink one less beer
a month and I'm gonna take that six
bucks that I spend on a beer month and
I'm gonna give three creators two bucks
or whatever it is so I they really did
do that well there were other things
that I loved about you know they did
some of the backend stuff so I was doing
voice and video chats with groups small
groups and one-on-one people over the
last couple months we eliminated the
one-on-ones because I just simply didn't
have any time anymore
but I've loved by the way doing the
group chats you know I do I still do a
series of these which we are phasing out
but I've met so many people and its
really cool so I spend about well at one
point I was going from 8 a.m. to 8 p.m.
I was a whole day of talking people
where I would bounce around I talked to
somebody in Japan and then somebody in
Australia and then you know somebody in
Mexico and Brazil and Iceland and Sweden
and blah blah blah it was like man the
amount of perspective that I would get
and just talking to interesting people
who were thinking about the same things
all over the world it's pretty freaking
awesome so patreon this is not I don't I
don't hate jack conte I don't hate this
Jaqueline heart that had a
trust in safety it's like I think
they're not particularly good at their
jobs I think that they're not standing
up for the right principles but if
either one of them want to come and talk
to me again I guess I'd be happy to do
it although everything Conti said to me
last time
turned out turned out either to be
intentionally lying but I don't like to
attack people's motives so he was either
mistaken didn't realize the problems
that were coming down the pike or just
didn't know what he was talking about I
don't know which one of those is is the
truth
yo Dave check out YouTuber law he's a
tech lawyer looking to take action seems
like he has a lot of support from the
legal end so I know people have sent me
the videos I haven't seen them yet but I
will take a look at that the IDW has
made my husband and I closer we need
more IDW women to speak up I know we
exist absolutely you do look there are
there are there are plenty of women from
ion and christina hoff sommers
and I would say Caitlyn Flanagan and and
Claire Lehmann and you know there there
are plenty of others but yeah I think we
could this is the irony of the whole
thing right it's like we don't care
about identity politics but you want to
feel that there are people from all
sorts of walks of life that are
represented with good ideas not because
of this color of their skin or their
sexuality or gender or any of that but
yeah look I promise you guys as long as
I can keep doing this show and we can
keep making this thing work I will I
will keep finding people regardless of
any of those immutable characteristics
and if it happens to be more women then
so be it let's see you and Jordans
bromance is awesome please come with
Jordan to the UK soon and somewhere a
student can afford tickets have a great
day name we did about six or seven stops
in the UK which was actually totally fun
and cool and it was nice to bounce
around the country one of the most fun
things that I did in the UK was during
one of our days in London I had a couple
hours off and I spent the day at Makayla
school Jordan's daughter happens to be
named Makayla but that is not connected
to this you may remember my former guest
Catherine Birbal Singh who was on at the
end of August
and she she runs a school called Makayla
she used to be a big lefty she realized
how leftism was teaching just no
personal responsibility and always
kicking the can down the road and
throwing money at things and she has
this school or they take inner-city kids
from every walk of life and they they
teach them how to be responsible smart
self-aware adults I mean I so I sat it I
didn't know what I was doing I just
showed up there she's like you're gonna
have lunch with these kids i sat at a
table with with a bunch of kids like
eight kids and we had this incredible
conversation they took me to all these
classrooms I gave a talk at the end of
the day to the to the teachers there but
they they you know they're not allowed
to talk they're allowed to talk about a
specific topic during lunch they can't
talk in the hallways they have to walk
on certain sides of the thing like it
sounds sort of authoritarian in a way
but they're teaching these kids
incredible personal responsibility it's
it's pretty awesome alright let me jump
back in here shoutouts to Kyle Matt and
Scott and just a reminder Dave Rubin
comm / donate if you do it while I'm
doing this right now 25 bucks monthly
you're gonna get a Rubin report t-shirt
which will never be printed again
because it was the patreon shirt and you
will also get a signed autographed Rubin
report mug which I'm gonna sign for you
right here I'm surrounded by mugs right
now all right here we go um excited to
see Maxime on the show is there any
possibility of getting some more focus
on Canadian politics well there's
obviously something going on in Canada
yeah well we're gonna have Stephen
Harper former Prime Minister Stephen
Harper will be on the show I think in
January if I'm not mistaken and there
there really is something going on in
Canada related to free speech and all
this which is why Jordan obviously is
from Canada and Lindsey Shepard and Ezra
Levant and plenty of other people that
are fighting this fight are in Canada
let's see Dave will your platform allow
creators of legal erotic content writing
drawing photography yeah I'm talking
about what a lot of people call porn
again this is this is all about trying
to figure out what kind of platform we
want to build do we want absolutely
everybody on there should it be
invite-only do you need to be
recommended by a couple of people I know
anything I say right now is gonna make a
certain amount of people mad no matter
what we are talking all of this stuff
out so might look my general feeling so
I can only speak for myself for just a
second I can always only speak for
myself but particularly at this moment
my general feeling is I want
little gatekeeping as possible if you
are doing something that is legal if it
is legal in the country that you live in
then I would
I personally would err on the side of
that being completely fine on the
platform now the problem with that at
least optically is if you try to do that
then a certain amount of of people who
are doing all sorts of racist whatever
like truly racist and evil stuff they're
gonna all flock to that platform and
maybe that's gonna overrun all of the
the good decent stuff that's there
that's just an issue to deal with
because well even if even if you're okay
with that right well then you've got
then the mob that comes in after and
it's like see what this platform is see
what this platform is it's an alright
haven for evil racist and pornographers
in the rest of it and then whether you
want it to be a problem or not or
whether you believe in all of these
people's right to free speech or not if
they then come after your payment
processors the master cards and PayPal
well now you've still got a massive
headache so that's why we have to figure
this thing out in in a whole bunch of
steps okay wow there's a lot here thank
you for all your hard work Dave I may
just be a dumb mechanic but I find all
your content very important best of luck
to you and your adventures you're not a
dumb mechanic and thank you for that you
can view the Pareto principle through
two lenses one that says 80% of people
are worthless the other perspective says
that small businesses are more
productive globalism is dead it's like
how you snuck that in there well you
know it's funny about small businesses
because it really is one of the things
that I'm most proud of we have a
seriously great small business here we
have built something that I'm super
proud of that we as I said before we pay
of all of our health insurance for our
employees we give nice bonuses we treat
everybody well I try to let people take
more vacations than then you would at a
normal job and we we work with people
however however we can to make a good
business we have no debt we own
everything that we're doing here I mean
I'm dead in that in the in the home but
I mean we have you know we own all of
our equipment we've run a very
responsible business that I'm super
excited about but I remember once
Jonathan Chait who is a lefty writer
from either New York Magazine or The New
Yorker I'm blanking I think it's New
York magazine but somebody could let me
know
about a year or two ago I saw him tweet
something about how like small business
the phrase small business is just a it's
just like a made-up phrase bye-bye big
government or by Republican something
like that and I wrote back and I was
like you know I got to tell you I run a
small business and I'm super proud of it
and we have a couple we have several
employees and you know whatever and then
he retweeted me and he wrote back
several employees mocking the fact that
I only have several employees and I
thought this is this is exactly why
people don't like elite liberals and and
sort of the the the coast liberalism and
this big government nonsense it's like
wait a minute if I was a big company
you'd say I'm bad because I'm an evil
corporation now I'm a small business and
you mock me for only having several
employees I've created something I've
created content that's valuable I've
created jobs for people which I'm super
proud about I don't know that he's ever
created anything I don't want to make
this about him specifically but it's
like what is the right number if you
hate corporations and you hate small
business what's the right amount of
people that I should have hired that
then I would be in that sweet spot if I
had 16 employees are we good are we good
then like what are we really talking
about here and there and often there's
really no answer because they have some
sort of they if I just have an idea of
what's right instead of having anything
to do with what reality what is
realistically practical and Jonathan
shade is from New York magazine Keith
Andrew Angela and Camille thank you guys
very much appreciate it and it's Dave
Rubin comm / donate guys I'm signing
mugs and I'm giving away t-shirts here
we go
might I suggest having Bishop Baron and
Jordan Peterson share a discussion on
your show that would be quite an event I
think that would be it would be really
really really interesting and I know
that the bishop is a big fan of of
Jordan so I will see if I can make that
happen
have you looked at decentralized
solutions like Alexandria / open index
protocol I think the problem needs to be
solved at the protocol level so payment
is decentralized separate from content
delivery I don't want to answer that one
specifically suffice to say as I said
earlier I have many phone calls tomorrow
so I think think about it that way hey
Dave I realized a while ago that I'm
bisexual and I'm having trouble
accepting it as part of my identity do
you have any advice based on your own
coming
experience well that's it's nice to get
away from the topic for just a second um
the only the only advice I can give on
on anything I think related to sexuality
or anything like that is you just have
to be yourself
like you can try not to be yourself you
can I did it for many many years I'm
gonna be writing about this in my book I
came out of the closet way too late I
think I did damage to myself I think
emotionally psychologically it damaged
my relationships family all sorts of
things now you don't just put aside one
day and are magically fixed I think then
you have a lifetime of sort of repairing
those things so you know it's funny I
don't regret anything I did because I
got to a place in life that's good but
we all lived with some of the scars of
our former selves you know but I would
say if you are what you would Popeye I
am what I am and that's all that I am I
mean if you are something whether you're
gay or bisexual whatever you are if you
are it's like you got to be it now
whatever that means to you and if you
think that people aren't going to accept
you for it then maybe you should find
some other people to be around and
that's not a fun thing to say or cool
either but be who you are it's all you
can do you know like it's hard to live
one life this is what I would say it's
hard to live one life on this earth
right like living one life is hard what
does Jordan talk about her life is
suffering man you got to figure out some
way to pilfer some some pleasure out of
it be on an adventure that that Gibbs
that is rewarding to you and meaningful
and all of those things I think I've
been able to do that but like--imagine
trying to live two lives and this is
what people who are closeted have to do
and people people are closeted for all
sorts of reasons I would say
conservatives now are more closeted than
gay people in a lot of ways because
everywhere I go I meet people that are
just basic decent conservatives who
might be pro-life or prone to are afraid
to tell anybody what their political
views are now you know what it's like to
be in the closet the closet isn't just
the closet is just there's just room for
a1 there and it's just you and your
thoughts and that is a lonely place but
it's hard to live life as one person now
imagine trying to live life as two
people all the time it's not fun and
and yeah it's not good it's not good I
hope that I hope that had some value
shoutouts to Benjamin Beverley and
Patricia and mugs to Philip and to Thor
speaking of Thor you know I've been on
planes like I don't know how many
freaking plane rides I've taken in the
last year but I've watched Avengers
infinity war like 10 times and I like it
better every time like it really is just
spectacular I can't wait til the next
one so this is for you Thor and alright
where are we where are we
we'll be sure to send you monthly via
PayPal till your new platform comes out
keep fighting good fight thank you very
much
Happy New Year Dave and everyone how do
we solve the whole problem when it
starts with the payment processors it's
like we need our own payment processor
yeah again so we've hit this a couple of
times but maybe there will be a payment
processor or maybe there is one out
there or maybe I have a phone call with
one of them tomorrow with with with the
ability to stand up to the mob or maybe
that have some outside-the-box thinking
solutions to some of these things so we
shall see let's see
thanks Dave for so many hours of great
content leading me to Petersen Rogen
will the Weinstein brothers and so many
other interesting people thank you for
giving us hope for the next generation
of freedom to think it's scary raising
my children in this generation keep
fighting well thank you for that and you
know one of the things that I when I go
to college is that I talk to students
about night I just spoke at Turning
Point USA did their student action
summit which was great Peterson spoke
there Greg Gutfeld and and Candace Owens
charlie Kirk Calcasieu boot was actually
like a Rubin report reunion basically
but one of the things that I always say
to these kids it's like if you think
that you're kind of not saying what you
think right now if you think that you're
silenced and your teachers are teaching
nonsense and all these things if you
don't stand up now do you think it's
gonna be any better in three years do
you think it's gonna be any better
magically in four years the people that
want to take away your rights that want
to silence you they have no problem
doing it now I'm not saying be as awful
as them be a little better than them
it's not that hard they're pretty awful
be a little better than them but if
you're what would it be like for your
kid if you're 18 right now you're in
college right you're a freshman
in college you're getting indoctrinated
with this leftist craziness right
and this intersectional lunacy and all
of this stuff it's like do you think
that if you don't fight it when you're
young you're 18 you've got you know a
chip on your shoulder and you've got
energy and enthusiasm and you're ready
to take on life it's like if you don't
do it then you're not gonna suddenly be
27 and you're gonna be married and have
car payments and a mortgage and a dog
and a blah blah blah and your backs
gonna hurt and a whole bunch of other
stuff and be like and now I'm gonna take
on the world actually you'll never do it
so do it now before it's too late
and I would say that to somebody that
doesn't agree to me okay all right you
know what let's let's throw to a wide
shot for a second just so people can see
how many mugs I'm surrounded by here we
got a lot of mugs people there's a whole
bunch on the left side of me - we got
mugs being signed every which way so if
you guys want to jump in on a mug I'm
guessing we probably have around 50 left
maybe of the stash I'm gonna room in my
closet again I can't believe it
it's Dave Rubin calm slash donate and
and you'll get it you'll get a mug and
we're gonna send you your t-shirt I got
a couple unsigned ones down here and I'm
giving shout out standing when the jumps
on five dollars and above so there you
go Dave I'm a huge fan of yours and
Colin Moriarty your show first
introduced me to him I hope you and
Colin can find a way to do more
interviews together even though you'll
no longer be on patreon I love Colin you
know one of the beauties of this show is
that I've you've watched me in real time
become friends with some of my best
friends now you know what I mean like
obviously Jordan and I and and you know
Sam and his wife just came over for
dinner the other night and Colin and I
have become best of friends and people
go Xion has become an incredibly close
friend and guide sad and an a-hole and
Eric has become like an older brother to
me and I love Brett and this the whole
crew it's like these things have
happened in real time in front of you
it's really cool actually one of the
things that I love doing about this most
it's like not only do I get to learn
from these people every week like I
really I sit here and listen it's why I
don't sit and stare at notes and go oh I
got to ask you this and I got to get you
with that and that whole thing it's like
if you could sit in a room with somebody
and just be you can learn and if you can
learn I think you'd be a better person
so I'm a better person not a perfect
person got
got a plenty to work on shout out to
Paul thank you my friend
let's see excited to see what bubbles up
in the near future to fill asila Tate
the max effective transfer of complex /
tricky ideas each additional platform is
a new opportunity to work out the kinks
yeah you're actually totally right you
know one of the interesting things here
is and I said this right at the
beginning it's like Jordan and I are
working on this thing there are a
zillion people that work want to work on
a zillion different things there are
people that are saying it's you got to
go crypto right now there are people
saying you got a you know that's a
two-year plan there are people saying
that the payment processors won't be a
problem if you as long as you're sort of
decentralized off patreon in my view
that they're just gonna nip us off
slowly that way
nobody knows what the answer to any of
this is but again this is why how cool
is it that there is a problem like think
about it this is what's so cool about
being a human and and being alive in a
free society right it's like there is a
problem you guys see a problem you
watching this right now you see that
there's a problem I happen to be one guy
talking about that problem but you might
be able to solve it and maybe what you
do the amount of people that have
reached out to us it's like guess what
we do read our emails sometimes people
reach out to Jordan and he forwards me
something he says what do you think
about this all right forward it to Eric
and I go this might seem like something
so we're all trying to figure it out
doesn't mean that there's a you know
everyone it's like I saw when I
announced that I was leaving patreon it
so a couple verified people on Twitter
go after me like oh you see both you if
you really wanted to fight free speech
you wouldn't just get off patreon you
get off Twitter you get off Facebook you
get off YouTube and it's like you know
what everyone can sit there and complain
about everything and [ __ ] and moan
about how everyone's not perfect but
sometimes sometimes some people stand up
and do something I think that's what
we're doing here I really do all right
shoutouts to Jonas - Ian - Amanda OH -
Amanda Lee Amanda Lee who I just sent
you a note
your brother reached out over the
holidays I'm sorry I didn't get it to
you before Christmas but you are a
student at UCLA and you just completed
the LSAT congratulations there you go
okay holy [ __ ] there's a lot going on
here we the people are super proud of
what you're doing have you reached out
to get Matt Christensen on the show he's
welcome to come on I don't know that
I've reached out to him specifically I'd
like to do it in studio he said
Montana or something but yeah if he's
watching what Matt will make it happen
support from Australia where the world
has also got batshit crazy hoping to see
Jordan Peterson here in February my
government already banned Gavin McGinnis
from entering the country
we've got about about ten stops in
Australia they sold out crazily quickly
so then we're supposed to be going after
Australia we go to New Zealand I
actually can't go to New Zealand
unfortunately I would love to go to New
Zealand it's like how many chances does
someone get to go to New Zealand but my
family my folks and my brother and
sister and spouses and kids and
everything we do one week of vacation a
year together and that happens to be
then so I'm leaving Australia so I'm
missing I'm be at all the shows up until
the 16th in Sydney then I'm gonna miss
like two or three shows Jordan goes to
New Zealand and then from there he's
then going back to Australia but it
doesn't make sense for me to fly all the
way back across the world to do that
although I've done some crazy flying
things you know the craziest thing that
I did on the whole tour so far was I
left the UK on a Friday night - on a
Friday afternoon to get back to Los
Angeles to go to - my good friend and
former Reuben report gets Bob Saget and
his beautiful wife Kelly Rizzo to go to
their wedding in Santa Monica so I got
in that morning after like a 10-hour
flight from the UK or however long that
slide is went to the wedding had a great
time was slow dancing by the way next to
Billy Crystal and his wife and I think
our butts kind of touched and then then
had the wedding and then immediately the
next day flew all the way back to
Amsterdam which was completely bananas
but it was like you got it you got to do
what you got to do shoutouts to Marilyn
- Erin - Robert - Shaun it's a Emilio
thank you guys appreciate it Dave Rubin
comm / donate guys you guys truly are
the lifeblood of this show look I don't
want to belabor the point but I've got
several networks that want me to join
them we could do all sorts of things
where I start doing live reads and more
live ads and all that stuff I like doing
it the way we've done it and if we can
just if we can to quote Blanche DuBois
or Blanche Devereaux as the case may be
at least in my world I've always
depended on the kindness of strangers
you know what I mean like you guys
if you guys keep funding this thing
we'll keep doing it this exact same way
and we'll keep figuring out other ways
to grow and expand oh and by the way one
of the things that that I'm planning on
doing so you know we have this great
partnership with learn Liberty which is
a classical liberal nonprofit and we
work with them for about two years they
gave us something some of my favorite
episodes they gave us with Georgetown
professor Randy Barnett who talked about
the foot vote that was one of the
episodes that really changed my views on
small government and with Steve Davies
and Deirdre McCloskey
and Sean hopwood and and they sponsored
our episode with Phil DeFranco just
because they liked him they never even
met the guy but they they thought they'd
sponsor that episode so we worked at
them for about two years they wanted to
sign on for another year and I just kind
of wanted to go in another direction so
we actually do have a new nonprofit that
I've done some stuff with I might as
well just tell you we're gonna be doing
a little bit more with with the iron
Rand Institute they I've done some live
events with them obviously I've had your
on Brook in here who's been it was a
great guy who's been very influential
for me and we're gonna be doing some
sponsored shows with them and get them
in there because they because this is a
beautiful thing they actually believe in
the ideas of Objectivism so we're gonna
do a couple shows where it's objectivism
verse and you'll be able to see people
sort of tangle and spar over ideas and
they're putting their money where their
mouth is so that's actually pretty cool
all right
um hey Dave is there someone who you
have come across that thinks like Thomas
soul or who or who you think could
become the next Thomas all well I don't
think they'll ever be another Thomas
soul is there anyone I mean I'm sure
there's some people out there well I
would say at some level although he's
probably a little more left than Thomas
I would say Coleman Hughes is is sort of
on the way in a certain respect and
Coleman I've had on here who's a great
guy and really bright I don't know could
there ever be another time it's all
probably not probably not shoutouts to
Gareth - John - Jeff - Jason - Alban and
- Timothy and then what I do with my
marker we got a couple mugs coming Troy
and Nathan you guys are getting mugs
signed right there Troy there you go
that's your mug Nate
it's coming okay Dave Rubin calm /
donate guys I really do appreciate it
and by the way you know we're not gonna
if you look at how many times we did
like serious like fundraising over these
last couple years we did it I tried to
do it maybe once or twice a year not
even that I don't intend on doing this
type of thing all the time
it's just at this brief moment where you
know the other thing that's funny is
that so we were at as I said around
thirty grand a month for most of the
last year on patreon then the then the
sargon thing happened we went down to
like you know 25 or something then I
started really talking about it a couple
weeks ago with Jordan we went down
another ten then I made this
announcement now we're down to like
we're down to like fourteen let's say on
there even despite the fact that I have
announced to the patrons I'm leaving but
there's 14 grand just sitting there
because a lot of times people sign up
and then never think of it again I'm
gonna close the account either way so
it's like there gonna be a lot of people
who maybe just signed up and that aren't
that active in all of this or maybe
don't pay attention to Twitter or
whatever and it's like that's why we
have to do some of these things where we
talk about these things and do these
live streams into videos and the rest of
it a shout out to Heidi and Magnus that
is a great name Magnus you are getting a
mug right there I'm gonna write your
name on it because Magnus is an all-star
named Magnus you're getting a mug
brother there you go all right let's see
paying for freedom how much for a mug
dave rubin com / donate if you sign up
for 50 bucks
monthly we're gonna send you a mug right
now and I'm gonna sign it for you you
said speaking in Montana at the
University of Wyoming as a graduate of
both Montana State Bozeman and
University of Wyoming Laramie I forgive
you for the mix-up keep up the battle
Dave I got a lot on my mind lately it
was University of Wyoming at Laramie
that's where it was
that was that was fun I actually went
out with some of the students there from
Turning Point after we had a good time
except like a bottle of ketchup exploded
on me which actually did happen let's
see
to determine someone's true convictions
look no further than the personal
sacrifices they've made to uphold them
love you Dave and keep up the great work
Tim thank you well thank you Tim I
appreciate that
[Music]
these attacks are not new the banks have
been strangling gun manufacturers and
sellers for years are you interested in
speaking out on other rights well that
would be interesting just to find out a
little bit more about that I've heard
that I've heard that from people that
work in the adult film business that
they've said they have all sorts of
problems with payment processors and
things like that again this is where I
would say that generally if I was
running things and I don't want to run
things but I would say if you're
following the laws of the the country in
an American's case the state that you
live in but that everything basically
should be allowed if you're breaking
those laws then we have a different
problem but yeah that's where I would
fall out on that what are your thoughts
on Bitcoin do you think it could replace
normal currency so first off we are
accepting Bitcoin now we're also
accepting Bitcoin cash we're looking
into litecoin and etherium and a couple
of the others but our Bitcoin address is
at Dave Rubin comm / donate I have a lot
to learn on crypto trust me I'm trying
to learn I have a whole bunch of calls
tomorrow talking to crypto people on all
sorts of different fronts look because
it's on the blockchain and it's not
centralized there is a power to this
type of currency that I think will will
be more important as we move forward
there's still all sorts of problems
related to how quickly you can do
transactions and is it really is it is
it a is it a money the way cash is where
you can quickly do transfers or is it
more of like a gold standard sort of
thing I got a ton to learn so I don't
even wanna speak out of school here but
I but I promise you that I'm learning as
fast as I can okay are the donations
through patreon or other that you
receive tax yeah they are I have to
report everything and we just I just did
my year in taxes with my accountants it
was not pretty you want to become a you
want to become a libertarian pretty
quick start paying taxes hey Dave just
transferred from patreon to your
platform monthly thank you very much
same with Jordan B Peterson do you know
if Bill Whittle would love to see you
talk with him yeah had bill Whittle on
about a year ago check it out just put
his name in slash Rubin report Rubin
report in the
and the thing there all right we are
about an hour and a half in holy cow
I've been talking for a long time let's
throw in the why chat because I'm
surrounded by mugs there's a whole bunch
of mugs you can't even see over there
and remember you can get the t-shirt the
Reuben report t-shirt at $25 and we'll
send these things out to you pretty
quick we'll try to get all these out
within a within a day or two my guys are
gonna kill me for saying that but we
will do the best we can on that to get
these out to you and yes these will
never be printed where am I looking over
here these will never be printed again
because these were the shirts that we
were given out to our patrons so we had
about 200 of them or so left and we're
clearing out stock here at the Rubin
report today let's see um exciting to
witness the birth of a cultural paradigm
where people of different ideas unite
under the aegis of good faith and
reasoned discussion let's make history 1
dark numbers agent time let's do it
let's roll what is your opinion on
Brazilian prime minister Boas our bowls
are narrow regarding there's a lot of
things moving here deforestation of the
rainforest PS I'm a Christian I baked
you a cake though you know I don't know
enough about him but it sounds like he
really hates Marxism and he's and he's
really pushing Brazil to become more of
a world leader and that he actually is
for capitalism and he's trying to get
some of the SJW stuff out of the schools
I just saw a tweet by him a day or two
ago so on that front and as again I
don't know a ton about him that all
sounds good to me and as a Christian I
appreciate your offer to bake me a cake
that would that would be very nice of
you thank you very much
let's see a shout outs to mil hi -
William - Trenton - Daniel - Juanita -
Henrik - Greg - Sam - Alexis and -
Andrew thank you guys very much men you
guys look you know I said before that
when we originally went on patreon the
night before I was like I don't know
that I just destroyed my career that I
just cause my partner and my friends to
not have jobs anymore and the whole
thing and you know look I knew this
coming through because we have a couple
different revenue sources so so fan
funding is the bulk of it as I said
patreon has been about 60 to 70 percent
of our Rev there is YouTube Rev but the
problem with building a business around
YouTube Reb as it goes like this you
just never know when it's gonna go up
and down it's also seasonal where it
gets better in like November in December
before the holidays and then January
February are pretty bad and with the
monetization and all that we also do
audio podcast reads that's one way we do
it
and as I said there would be plenty of
opportunities if I right now wanted to
start doing ads just this way just on
YouTube like this we could make a [ __ ]
ton of money I mean far more than I was
making on patreon I just don't know that
that's the route that I want to go I
don't begrudge anyone for doing it you
know it's funny when when Shapiro does
it it's become part of his shtick it's
actually kind of fun when he does it I
just I just like doing it this way I
also be for the purposes of the
conversation and this is not a knock on
anybody but for the purpose of the
conversation when I sit in this room and
they close that door we go straight
through we do not edit for content I sit
there I look at that person I stare at
them in the eyes and we and we go for it
right and I don't know that I would want
to be stopping to read ads in the middle
of that again that's not merging anybody
the way anyone has to do anything it's
just what I've become accustomed to and
the more that the more that you guys
allow me to do that I think the better
work that I could do shoutouts to
Christian and to Stefan thank you guys
okay here we go um Dave I love your
content as well as the IDW as a whole I
just wanted to make sure you're
subscribed to PewDiePie please confirm I
am subscribed to PewDiePie I don't know
if it's actually through the Reuben
report YouTube channel but it through I
have another one that I am subscribed to
the PewDiePie he's funny he's funny he
did this really funny video he actually
mentioned me in a video about the whole
patreon thing maybe a week or two ago
but he just does these holiday he opens
this video like and it's like this mock
sort of cartoony CNN and he's like I'm
Gloria Borger and it's like what he's
just the guy's just funny I like him
let's see thanks for what you do you
should interview retiring representative
trey gowdy about free speech and regards
to national security and censorship
there and I would be happy to do that
let's see if we can reach out to him
good idea have Neil Ferguson back onto
discuss what's going on with credit
processors from a historical perspective
what a great idea I got to tell you one
of the interviews I knew that that Neal
was a was a brilliant historian and was
outspoken and all that but I did not
fully expect him to be the absolute
powerhouse that he was he flew in he
liked walking he had just landed he
walks in he like pound some water he
sits down and he just goes and we did I
think about an hour and twenty minutes
and we could have done much more but he
had to jump back on the plane but he's a
brilliant brilliant guy he's his wife by
the way is ayaan Hirsi Ali and he when
he talks about her the interview it's
like you know some people could talk
about their wife or their husband and
they're just like saying something nice
and it's just meaningless but the the
way that he talks about that woman it's
like wow that is that is what love
really is will you work with software
engineers to create solutions with
freedom as a core value yeah this is
what people are reaching out to us as I
said I'm not making this up well I got
Google engineers reaching out to me I
got people at Facebook reaching out to
me we're gonna try to figure this all
out it's a lot to chew off Sean M a
shout out Leonard a shout out and Sean W
for a mug all right I got five more mugs
right there and a bunch over there let's
get rid of all these mugs people there
we go another mug okay let's see much of
the talk between you and your colleagues
highlights the issues around radical
leftist indoctrination at universities
are there still reasons to pursue an
education at these institutions in the
current climate ah this is such a tough
question and I get this a lot because I
speak at colleges look there are a
million reasons to go to college I think
that that aren't necessarily the
academic reasons let's just put academia
aside for a second there are social
reasons meeting people from different
walks of life meeting people from
different parts of the country or
different parts of the world living in a
dorm living in you know when you move
off campus maybe and you live in a small
house with some friends like learning
how to socialize with other people not
under your parents roof but not under
the the roof of where you're gonna live
with say your spouse one day or
something like that so there's all sorts
of social reasons learning learning Teta
hang out and have fun and maybe smoke a
joint and have a beer and
what and whatever else that you're gonna
do to help become a person that is all
what part of what the college experience
is like
now if the academic side of it is just
indoctrination then man it's tough I
would say the most important thing you
can do as a parent is try to steer I
suppose your your children to schools
that are going to be respectful of ideas
that are gonna be respectful of
defending free speech University of
Chicago is doing a great job of this
there are schools that are still doing
this by the way I spoke down in Clemson
they've got a great a program down there
about capitalism and free markets that I
thought they're doing a nice job in
Jordan and I spoke to a small group of
students there and then did a big talk
there's all sorts of schools that are
doing interesting things Chapman
University here outside of Santa Barbara
where Michael Shermer teaches I think is
doing a nice job defending free speech
but yeah if you're gonna just send them
if you're gonna send them to Berkeley to
just be indoctrinated and then now
that's palm but that being said I've
given talks to the Berkeley College
Republicans and they're there and
they're fighting for what they believe
in so hopefully you've given your child
enough of a understanding of what the
world is or the basic bones and how to
go about life that they're not going to
go to the school forget everything you
taught and then just come out a zombie
on the other side but that's tough and
I'm some of that's not a parent it's a
little bit hard for me to to say that
with full gussto or something shoutouts
to Michael - Angie - Blake - Ashley -
Toni - Collin - Gerry and a mug for
Robin all right Robin
that's yours Robin there you go all
right what are some books that changed
your life love to show and everything
that you're doing thanks Dave I like
this question so first of every book
that we have we could go to the wide
shot for a sec every book that's on our
set right now including some books that
you can't see over there these are all
former Rubin report guests so there's
Amy Chua Steven Pinker you're on Brooke
there's teal there's Ferguson Kelly
Carlin Saget David from Sam Harris is
over there Douglas Mari I mean Thomas
all Scott Adams bah bah bah bah
so I saw I've read most of these books
you know the first the first year of the
show at least maybe the first two years
the show I I read every book of every
that we had on and then suddenly my
schedule got so crazy it was impossible
to do I also found sometimes in certain
interviews if I knew a little bit less
about the the specific topic of the book
let's say I could ask better questions
because I didn't I wasn't sort of
subconsciously leading in a certain way
I was actually going in the most open
way so when I had Jordan on even I think
12 rules was right I mean the Jordan I
had knew each other pretty well but then
certainly before the tour
I think either either 12 rules had just
come out or was just about to come out I
had not read the book and we went
through the rules and it's like now I
know I know the rules inside and out and
he and he does these awesome really
they're truly incredible talks about
them all the time so but okay but it's
the books that I would recommend the
book that I would recommend more than
anything else because it affected me in
such a deeply profound way is billions
and billions by Carl Sagan it's Carl
Sagan it's his last book he actually
died before he finished it so then his
wife Ann Druyan who was also a professor
at Cornell she finished it for him Carl
Sagan if most of you know who Carl Sagan
is he but he wrote cosmos and he did the
TV show cosmos and he used to go on the
whole Johnny Carson Tonight Show and the
the joke that Johnny Carson would say
Johnny Carson would always mock him and
say you say billions and billions except
it turns out that he actually never said
that phrase that's why he named the book
billions and billions anyway it's just a
great book about about the way humans
react to each other how how important
science and belief are and a whole bunch
of other things so yes I would check
that out if I were you a shout out to
Marshall thank you my friend
let's see do you think the next election
will see more people move towards the
middle with their votes or further away
from moderation also you're my fav Dave
alright I appreciate that
well I tweeted out yesterday like a six
tweet thread about sort of what my
predictions are for for the year I look
I think that the left unfortunately at
all the markers over the last couple
years where they could have done a
little self reflection and said that we
shouldn't be in tight entity politics we
shouldn't judge people as groups
we should look at the individual more
things that used to be liberal
principles right we shouldn't look for
the government to solve everything JFK
Liberal Democrat JFK s not what the
country can do for you as way you can do
for the country that's the reverse of
what they say now that imagine if Bernie
started saying that they would not be
happy with Bernie so I think that the
left we're gonna see like a truly
bananas left that is going to get worse
and worse and worse what I and the media
is gonna keep feeding it and giving it
all the energy that's the worst part
what I think will will happen subtly is
what's been happening subtly which is
there is a really interesting group of
say moderate conservatives and
libertarians and some Trumper 's and
some disaffected liberals who are coming
together with pretty moderate stances
now who is the leader of that like I
don't think I don't think ultimately
that Trump is the leader of that even
though by no means do I have Trump
derangement syndrome and I think he's
done a lot of good things on policy
front and forget Twitter for a second so
I think that will continue to be built
that that group but what it's about
where will it get its energy from
ultimately who will be the leader of it
and what is it
like is it a more moderate Republican is
ben shapiro gonna run for president i
mean who knows could it be nikki Haley I
mean I'd probably vote for nikki Haley
and that would really flip identity
politics on its head right now you've
got a brown woman Republican well what
are they gonna do with that
so yeah it's really it's interesting
stuff I might hope is that people who
will return to moderation we don't want
to look back when in 20 years from now
go man 2018 2019 those were the good old
days cuz now we're in the middle of a
civil war over twitter fights you know
anyway and it's like we still got a
pretty damn good here right for you may
think that all hell is it's so arbol
we're so mean to each other it's never
been worse you know read some of the
things that that Thomas Jefferson who I
love would say about his political
opponents or that they would say about
him it's like there were crazy crazy
things being said and attacking each
other and all that so it's like it may
feel crazy right now but also this is
where every now and again get off line
and go talk to real people and they're
actually pretty decent shoutouts to
James Ron and Colin alright guys we got
15 minutes left
Reuben com / donate I got a couple mugs
left you will get an autographed mug got
a lotta graph right here will get you
the exclusive Reuben report Reubens
select t-shirt that will never be
printed again because it was our patreon
t-shirt
we are leaving patreon On January 15th I
thank you guys for being surrounded by
mugs and support and love and all of
those things I'm just doing what I what
I think I should do
whoo here we go Thank You Andrea
I appreciate it Reuben you and the rest
of the IDW are the best keep up the good
work and never apologize to the leftist
for anything they are truly lost in
they're in desperate need of reasonable
voices like yours I'll bake you a cake
thank you you know it's funny too it's
like if you listen to what the media
will say it's like I look I went to this
turning-point thing the student action
summit at the end of December that I
mentioned as I said Prager was there and
gutfeld and Charlie Kirk and Candace and
Jordan and and a whole bunch of other
people brand him Tatum Brandon Tatum a
whole other people a whole bunch and I
met when I had me when I got there to
get backstage I don't know if I walked
in the wrong entrance or whatever but I
had to walk through like a crowd of
hundreds of people and everyone's coming
up to me and they were taking selfies
and I'm signing and stuff and all this
stuff and it's like these are great
people from every walk of life they're
every color and I met gay people and
straight people and I met Orthodox Jews
wearing yarmulkes and I met brown
Muslims and I met all these different
people and guess what they're all
conservatives they're all decent they're
all human they're open to ideas I went
onstage I gave a talk about the
differences that I have with
conservatives I'm pro-choice I know some
of them are not thrilled with gay
marriage a series of other things I'm
against the death penalty and they still
they still love it I got a great ovation
afterwards it's like these are not the
intolerant people but that's the way
it's always gonna be framed which also
brings me quickly to something on the
media that I wanted to address which is
you may have seen the New York Times
article from about ten days ago on the
patreon situation and the entire article
is nonsense it's it's it's almost
completely made-up it's written by a New
York Times journalist by the name of
Nellie Bowles she's the one who did the
article on Jordan and enforced
monogamy from from you know about a year
ago now and she frames the whole thing
ridiculously she refers to me as a
libertarian podcaster which I don't care
about being called a libertarian that's
fine but it's like you're only saying
that because you know in the minds of
your ultra-left
readers that when you say libertarian
that somehow means bad person like if
you were being an honest reporter and
not someone colorizing something you
would say dave rubin who refers himself
as a classical liberal but if what would
ever put that aside it doesn't even
matter the quote she gets from
Jacqueline Hart who's the head of trust
and safety at patreon is basically in
effect that Carl sargon of akkad said
these words meaning the n-word on the
platform and you're not allowed to do it
on the platform except he never said
those words on the platform so the whole
that's the most important quote of the
whole article that sets up everything
about why people are leaving and
everything else now then I tweeted at
her and and many other people did and
they got hundreds and thousands retweets
saying that the quote that she gave you
that is the backbone of the article is a
lie and it's like there's no correction
out of her New York Times doesn't give a
[ __ ] so it's like we are watching fake
news crumble and I say frickin let him
crumble alright how do you really feel
about that name shout-out to Scott and
Jay is getting a mug all right Jay let's
do it here we go alright that that's a
fine signature right there that might be
my best one of the day you are in luck
Jay okay do you think you'll face legal
challenges no matter what platform or
payment system you adopt I mean I
certainly hope not I'm not doing
anything illegal I don't intend on doing
anything illegal we're all all of us are
just trying I can't say all of us what I
can tell you that most of the people
that are talking to about these things
from the weinstein brothers to jordan
and everybody else it's like we want to
have we want to be able to be on
platforms where the information is not
being manipulated where people are
getting with what they're subscribed to
where if you send a tweet out that it's
not gonna be shadow band that you can
make an honest dime etc.etc
we're not trying to revolutionize the
world nobody wants to fight google does
you think that seems fun fighting google
let's fight MasterCard like you know I'd
rather play video games and go play
basketball take a walk with my dog
you know you mean it's like that's just
true
it's like do I think we're gonna face
legal challenges everywhere I mean this
is all part of I suppose growing a
business and we're gonna have to think
through all of these things but that's
why these are not I know people want the
Silver Bullet right now they want the
magic answer right now just be patient
be patient and that's why as I said a
couple of times now it's like we're
gonna get off patreon for now we're
gonna move everybody over to our website
that eliminates the middleman we may
have to deal with a payment processor
issue at some point but hopefully we'll
be able to fold that into whatever else
we're doing but right now it's if you
dig what I'm doing here and you want to
support it you have a way to do it Dave
Rubin comm / donate so there you go Dave
while you go on this adventure remember
you're not alone keep the words of CS
Lewis close to your heart adventures are
never fun while you're having them I
love that quote actually I'm very aware
of that trust me like trust me trust me
trust me I've been able to go across the
world in the last year and meet so many
people who are so kind and decent and it
has made me a better person it just has
and like when people come up to you and
say oh you know you affected me this way
or I watch you and I shared this thing
and now my brother and I aren't fighting
so much or whatever it is it's like it's
real man it's real I think I've told
this before but one of the shows that we
did with Jordan forget I think we're in
the UK there was a father and son
act the show by coincidence and the son
was like 16 and they hadn't I'm slightly
butchering this the son was like 16 and
they hadn't seen each other in four
years and they both just happened to be
at the show and then saw each other
started hysterical crying they came
backstage after like like amazing things
are happening if you open your eyes to
it and sometimes it just has to be
offline to make it happen much respect
for your decision Dave you're on the
right side of history don't abandon your
path yeah you know what I better do then
save the world
Jacob Thank You Vidar Thank You Ryan
thank you Mike thank you k Carla thank
you
all right guys ten more minutes ten more
minutes if you want a Rueben select mug
that will never be created again because
they were created for patreon I'll sign
it right here for you
fifty bucks on a monthly donation dave
rubin comm / donate t-shirts are right
here i feel like i should be selling the
the senate and forget it
and where's Ron Popeil when you need
them Tony thank you Laura thank you
super Chad I really enjoyed watching
your channel and exploring how you went
into things openly and listening you're
doing a great job you started my journey
on educating myself on current day
topics and asking Carter questions I
love to hear that that's what it's all
about you Jordan and Sam are the real
defenders of free speech is there
anything patreon / Twitter can say do to
regain the trust of true liberals like
you guys look if right now look there's
someone at patreon watching this right
like maybe Conte's watching this right
now or Jacqueline Hart or some of our
other representatives over at patreon if
you guys are watching this right now for
a this is nothing personal to you I am
just doing what I think is right because
you guys are not defending principles
that I believe are the most fundamental
basic American principles we have to be
able to exchange ideas with each other
we have to be able to exchange money
with each other we have to be able to
interact with each other now I get it
all these other platforms are doing
things Twitter's Manning people Facebook
bans people etc etc I felt this was the
right one to fight but Conte if you're
watching this right now or any
representative at patreon if you want to
come in here and talk about these things
and and tell me why I'm wrong about this
tell me why the platform isn't gonna do
this again
now I'd welcome it would I believe you
probably not because you already told me
that only manifest observable behavior
mob would get someone kicked off the
platform and that's not what happened in
this case and you also lied to the New
York Times and the New York Times
doesn't care that you're lying by saying
this happened on your platform which it
didn't happen but I but I want these
things to be better that's the funny
thing it's like when people people if I
complain about YouTube right people will
be like oh you what well you know you
should just get off YouTube I said this
before and it's like no you complain
about things and you fight for things to
be better so that hopefully your voice
can be heard that is that is the essence
of expressing what freedom is being a
free person in a free society doesn't
just mean laying there and taking it all
the time it means that you use what you
can use whatever those tools are within
the context of being a free person so
hopefully affect things better so if
enough of us rose up and said you know
what patreon we're not gonna take this
maybe they would change their minds
maybe
that there has to be I know there are a
couple people probably a patreon who
have a flickering brain cell who are
probably watching this or watched some
of the videos that Jordan and I did or
notice that Sam left or whatever that
are going maybe this is the wrong thing
and that's why that's why the people
that wanted the platform everybody are
they're afraid of ideas they're afraid
that if you hear an idea it could
completely change what you think about
everything and you'll turn against them
well you might because their ideas are
often pretty bad and they don't want to
they don't want to defend their ideas so
they think okay it's easier to just call
someone a racist Andy platform them now
I'm the winner
which is why it's so interesting that I
see so much intellectual flexibility on
the right these days where conservatives
will debate and talk to almost anybody
and be willing to defend those ideas and
it and it's almost gone on the Left
shout-out to Rachel - Danny - Will and
Mary you're getting the mug all right
Mary
here we go by the way guys some people
have told us do not wash these mugs in
the dishwasher because it might wash
away the the signature I'm using a very
fancy sharp and E industrial-strength
pen here but hand wash these lightly
that's the best way to keep the
signature on there all right we got we
got five more minutes oh by the way did
I mention I'm gonna be on Tucker Carlson
tonight talking about you're not gonna
believe this people free speech and
patreon so I will be on tonight I think
I'm on the second half of the show so
that's what's that eight o'clock Eastern
so I'll probably be on around 8:45
Eastern which is about 5:45 Pacific and
I mean look it's a guy a guy like Tucker
a guy like Tucker I four years ago I
thought he was like in complete
opposition to everything I think I think
he's shifted on some things I think I've
shifted on some things and that's why I
said 2018 was going to be the year of
unusual alliances say sam harris and
jordan peterson and say Kanye West
Donald Trump and and I think this year
there's gonna be there's gonna be a
quiet revolution of sanity I think
that's gonna be what's happening here Oh
again you know I do want to mention so
one of the things as we roll people into
Dave Rubin calm slash donate our hope is
that when we build this new thing we
will just be able to roll you right into
it cuz we don't want people to have to
sign up for things and cancel things and
sign up again all of that remains to be
seen and we're trying to
get out so this is just this is just
giving us breathing room right now to
figure out everything else okay guys
we've got five minutes left five minutes
left
Dave Rubin dot-com / donate do you want
the asserts I need room in my closet
back 25 bucks a month
monthly on Dave Rubin concise doing it
you're gonna get a t-shirt and you want
a mug we're gonna give you a mug $50 a
month you're gonna get a mug I'm gonna
sign it for you we're gonna get you the
t-shirt the whole freaking thing
Christian is getting a mug
that's right Christians getting a mug
okay five more minutes who else wants a
mug and shout out some giving shoutouts
Allen thank you very much let's see have
you seen Tim pools coverage of Sargon
and patreon especially his interview
with leat youtuber law I didn't see that
but I have seen some I've been in
contact constantly with Tim we may get
him in he's gonna be in LA I think the
end of January we may get him in here is
there any chance you could have an AM
Kap economist on to debate Weinstein on
his ideas I'm not sure which Weinstein
you're talking about but I assume you're
talking about Eric because he does more
on economics that would be interesting
you know I did a public event with with
Eric Weinstein and you're on Brook from
a RI Iran Institute in New York a couple
months ago which was really really good
and they really got into it about
regulation and maybe we can pull that
off as I said we're gonna be doing a
partnership with a RI over the next
couple months maybe I can get the two of
them to sit down so hang on to that are
the people reaching out to you from
Facebook and Google doing it out of the
fear of losing free speech are these
people worried about censorship yeah I
think people really have realized that
what's happening at these companies is
not good and they're quietly trying to
figure out ways to solve it and again I
say if these companies start cleaning up
their acts start respecting free speech
why is it that everyone that gets banned
is always on the right you can do it you
can you can literally anyone right now
watching this including myself could
start calling everybody or white
supremacists right I could call
everybody on the right or white
supremacist I could call Donald Trump or
white supremacists I could call Ben
Shapiro white supremacists and a white
nationalist and a KKK member I mean
these things that are that are wise and
they're
sort of damaging dishonest things you
can say about somebody nobody gets
banned for that there's plenty of other
things if you call people and people on
the Left do this to people on the right
all the time the other way you get
banned if you do it the other way so
this is a this is a problem this is this
is an asymmetric war shout-out to
Terrence and Ryan you're getting a mug
alright I got a couple more mugs there
can one of you guys come in here and
hand me those mugs let's move these last
month's I got five more mugs there let's
move them I got I got three minutes
people three minutes to move five bugs
Dave Rubin calm / donate I'm gonna sign
your mug I'm gonna give you a t-shirt
then I'm going to drink a little tea and
then I'm going to see Tucker Carlson we
got another Ryan for a mug may I have a
mug right there
hand me a mug one mug look at this the
magic of YouTube oops that's oh yeah
yeah wow you're getting the old school
mug Ryan is getting the old Reuben
report mug the big mug that I drink out
of myself these are these are the new
ones you're getting the big-ass mug Ryan
all right there you go
holy cow lots going on here alright guys
we got about two minutes left some then
when platforms abuse their status I feel
powerless when creators like you lead by
example I'm hopeful thank you for taking
the stand by the way will you vote for
Kanye in 2020 for good luck to you and
Happy New Year at this point you know
it's as likely as anything else we'll
see okay
have you considered having an
open-minded quantum physicist sit down
with you Jordan and Ben to discuss
conscientiousness truth and reality that
could be amazing who do you recommend on
that give me give me a name give me a
name shout out to man well I got to move
these last couple mugs people Dave Rubin
dot-com / donate I've read that one
let's see will you speak to the issue of
American Legislative Exchange Council
and why aren't we hearing more about the
anti-american policies being put into
place no one seems to know who they even
are I'm gonna have to include myself in
that I'm actually not totally sure what
you're talking about so hang tight hey
Dave I'm a seasoned iOS developer here
who can certainly help with the patreon
alternative and more how do I get
involved resume is ready go to
urban report calm / contact drop me a
line we're categorizing I can't respond
to all these emails right now as I said
I have like five jobs as is and now I'm
like a like a tech person but what I'm
trying to do is I have somebody that I
that I trust who knows a lot about all
of this who I'm forwarding all of these
emails to we're putting them all in a
database and I think maybe at some point
I may try to pull off a day where we
just invited gajillion people together
to talk this all out so if you if you if
you are developing you are interested
it's a good way to end all of this go to
rubin report comm slash contact drop us
a line and and I promise at some point
we will try to get back to you Logan
thank you very much okay just reminder
guys January 9th Bret Weinstein and I
I'm doing stand-up for about an hour and
then we're doing a live sit-down in
Ontario California at the Ontario improv
on January 30th I'm at Irvine California
at the Irvine improv with a member of
the IDW thank you to Christopher
January 29th I'm at where the hell am I
Cal State Fullerton Mamamia a lot going
on here
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna put this
down unless there's these last few shout
outs thank you guys that really like I'm
look at this I'm sitting in a room I'm
surrounded by a hundred mugs right now
you guys are making this thing happen
and it's it's in it's humbling it's
incredibly I'll keep going I'll keep
going if you keep going I mean that's
that's the best thing I can say right
sort of like Dirk Diggler speech when he
first was winning the awards in Boogie
Nights
he says I'll keep rockin and rollin if
you keep rockin rollin that's kind of
what I feel about this it's like let's
do this together I'm one guy I happen to
be doing this we there are a lot of
allies out there there there's a lot
more support for all of these ideas than
you're gonna hear about because the
other people have silenced everybody
pretty damn effectively but maybe that's
what that's what the beauty of this is I
wanted to say this earlier but so the
year was ending and I was I was going
away with my brother and sister for the
end of the year to take a couple days
off and I really was gonna try to
disconnect and you guys know I like to
try to get offline when I can and then
and then the sargon thing like broke and
I wasn't here I was sitting on a beach
in Florida and like I had my phone I was
like man this sucks like I needed to
just
like three or four days to just like
stare at the ocean and and clear my mind
but I know how important all this was
and then something hit me it was like
this was exactly how the year was
supposed to end it was like it was such
a great year and everything was tracking
so properly and then right at the end it
was like the world kind of flipped kind
of you know like life just life just
throws you these things life throws you
a lemon and what do you do you make
lemonade and it's like something weird
just happened here but I think that I
know that for me at least every time
something weird has come along the road
that if I've kept my wits about myself
and I've and I've been honest with
myself and the people around me that
we've been able to make the right
decisions to go forward I think that's
that's what I see for myself I think
it's probably what you see for yourself
and we'll just keep going so this does
feel right to me like if you would have
told me a month ago man you're gonna be
canceling patreon and giving up 30 grand
a month it's on there and having to
figure out all sorts of new stuff and
we're and we by the way we're completely
redoing our website and a whole bunch of
other things I would have been like
you're nuts like that I'm not gonna do
that I'm gonna voluntarily do that like
who gives up 60 or 70 percent of their
company's revenue voluntarily but I know
it's the right thing to do and and for
the financial hit that will take even
though obviously we're making some of it
back here it's like where there's no
risk there's no reward so we're just
gonna keep going
final shoutouts - Christopher -
Bernadette and Michael unless someone
else joins by the time I finish this
sentence you are getting the last mug of
the day so here we go
Michael's getting the last mug there we
go Michael that's for you really thank
you guys you know we'll have a couple
other we may do a couple other live
streams in the next week or so just so
we can let people know about what's
going on with the patreon situation this
is all unfolding as Jordan and I said
we're gonna be as open and honest with
you as we possibly can as we figure out
all of these things we're listening to
you and you know I think I think that's
it for now
stand up January 9th Ontario California
January 30th in Irvine California and I
got to stop talking for a bit about an
hour so that I can do this with Tucker
later so check check out Fox News about
8:45 or so Eastern Time with Tucker
Carlson thank you guys and good night
[Music]